Ein Hacker, und ich bin auch ein Hacker, bei euren praktischen Arbeiten und Basteleien, die euch mit Rat und Tat zur Seite steht, was immer ihr gerade bauen wollt. Ob es nun ein Schiff, ein Flugmodell, irgendeine Spielerei oder ein nützlicher Gebrauchsgegenstand ist, für alles werdet ihr eine Anregung finden und daraus sehen, wie ihr mit einfachsten Mitteln den gewünschten Erfolg erreichen könnt. Freilich, die Herstellung irgendeines Gegenstandes soll nicht allein der Zweck unserer Arbeit unseres Bastelns sein. Viele wertvoller noch als der äußere Erfolg ist jener Nutzen, den wir unbewusst aus der praktischen Beschäftigung selbst gewinnen. Wir lernen mit dem Handwerkszeug umzugehen, wir üben unseren erfinderischen Verstand, begreifen die Wichtigkeit genauer, wohldurchdachter Arbeit und bekommen durch die Erfolge unseres Schaffens ein berechtigtes Selbstvertrauen. Darin liegt der größte Wert jedes Bauens und Bastelns für das spätere Leben.
Der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, 30. Mai 2007, wie immer Zeit für das Chaos Radio. Heute Ausgabe 124. Heute zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club sind Tim, Steini und Fiedl. Schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend. Ich mach das jetzt auch so, dass ich nicht so viel Raum drauf habe.
Genau, genau. Tim hat gerade eine Episode vorgelesen aus einem hervorragenden Buch.
Ein Vorwort. Was ist das für ein Buch? Das erklärt mir der Fiedl, weil es nämlich sein Buch ist.
Genau, das hab ich mal mitgebracht, weil das passt thematisch vielleicht ganz gut. Das ist das Werkbuch Verjungen aus dem Jahre 1953. Und verfasst wurde es von einem Herrn, müsste ich kurz mal gucken, von Rudolf Wollmann.
Otto Mayer, Verlag Ravensburg.
Schönen Dank Herr Wollmann für das schöne passende Vorwort, auch nach 50 Jahren noch günstig. In diesem Buch stehen Dinge drin, wie baut man etwas selber? Wie baut man etwas selber? Genau, Aquariumpumpen, Radioempfänger, Gitarren, Lötkolben, Wind, Wasser, Wärmekraftmaschinen. Alle Dinge für das praktische und praktische Leben und völlig Freizeitgestaltung würde ich mal sagen. Top aktuell sozusagen. Ja, und damit sind wir mittendrin im Thema der heutigen Sendung. Mein Name ist Jürgen Jakob Kranz, ich habe noch gar nicht guten Abend gesagt. Grüß euch, schön, dass ihr da seid. Es geht heute für Leute, die denken, Chaosradio, das gibt es nur um Bits und Bytes und 0 und 1 und Dinge, die man nicht so genau kennt. Das ist nicht der Fall. Wir hatten in den letzten Sendungen sehr viel, ich sage mal, gesellschaftspolitische Themen. Es ging um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, es ging um den elektronischen Reisepass, es ging um den Bundestrojaner, es ging um viele Dinge, die jeden von uns betreffen, wenn er in irgendeiner Form online kommuniziert oder nur zur Sparkasse geht und da Geld holt. Heute wird es ein bisschen praktischer zur Sache gehen. Heute geht es nämlich ums Schrauben. Und zwar richtig so mit dreckigen Fingern und Werkzeug und allem drum und dran, um Dinge, die ihr selber baut, die ihr selber gebaut habt, die ihr vielleicht auch plant, die nicht mal unbedingt jetzt Software spezifisch sein müssen, sondern es kann auch die Heizung für den Plattenspieler sein, damit er nicht kalt läuft oder die Kühlung, damit er nicht heiß läuft oder was auch immer.
Genau, und deswegen haben wir auch so eine Schrauber-Gang zusammengeholt, wenn ich mich da mal rausnehme. Du hast ja auch am Wochenende geschraubt, oder?
Ich habe nicht geschraubt. Ich habe auf etwas vertraut, was normalerweise nicht stattfindet, nämlich technische Selbstheilung. Ich bin durch den Regen gefahren mit der Morpete und leider ist etwas Wasser in die Zündspule gekommen. Dann lief sie nur noch auf einem Top. Und ich dachte, Zündung platt, hervorragend. Dann geben wir eine Schrotflinte, einen Schraubstock und einen Maisel und dann werde ich das Ding dann so beerdigen. Am nächsten Morgen ging alles wieder. Ich hatte eigentlich nicht geglaubt, dass sowas funktioniert, aber es geht wirklich.
Einfach durch Trocknung, oder was?
Verdunstung heißt das Phänomen.
Wo hatte ich den Sturm erwischt?
Der Sturm hat mich erwischt in Wismar. Da kam die schwarze Wolke rüber und dann stand ich bis zum Knöchel im Wasser. Man musste aber noch 15 Kilometer fahren.
Das heißt du hast einen Wochenendurlaub in Wismar gemacht?
Ich war ein bisschen länger unterwegs. Wir sind an der Ostsee lang gefahren, Richtung Kiel hoch. Wir waren unter anderem auch, passt zum Thema, kann ich dir schön nochmal berichten, war in Heiligendamm. Hab mir die Vorbereitung zum G8-Gipfel angeguckt. Zaun, man möchte es nicht mal mehr Zaun nennen. Wenn du da stehst, möchtest du nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln. Das Ding ist 3, 5 Meter hoch, glaube ich, tief in der Erde massiv verankert, mit einer Rolle Natustacheldraht oben drauf, durch den Wald um Heiligendamm. Das ist ein richtig alter, schöner Wald. Da haben sie eine 4 Meter breite Schneise rein gehackt, damit dieser Zaun da hingestellt werden kann. Heiligendamm ist wie eine Landzunge, und die Landstraße geht unten lang. Man hat also wie ein Dreieck Straße rein, Straße raus, auf der Straße rein und der Straße raus. Es wurde dann ein Graben gefräst, in dem ein automatisch hoch fahrbares Stahlschott installiert wurde, damit man da, wenn man ein Bösewicht ist, nicht mehr durchfahren kann.
Aber nur auf den Straßen, nicht auf der vollen Strecke.
Nein, nicht auf der vollen Strecke, du kommst eben auf die Straße nicht mehr rein und nicht mehr raus. Der Zaun wurde ja heute auch zugemacht. Das Ganze hat schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck von Staatsgrenze. Heiligendamm selber, da gibt es vor dem Kempinski, diesem weißen Schlosshotel, diesem sehr teuren, wo man sich nicht mal eine Serviette leisten kann, wenn man mal die Nase putzen muss, da gibt es den Finkling von Heiligendamm, das ist quasi so eine Art Wahrzeichen, das ist ein riesen Ding, dreieinhalb Meter mal zwei Meter mal zweieinhalb Meter, riesengroßer Stein mit Inschriften, der lag mal in der Ostsee, den haben sie dahingestellt. Und dann gab es einen Testlauf mit den Fotografen und die haben dann irgendwann gesagt, ist alles ganz schön, allerdings ist der Stein leider im Weg, wenn wir die Tribüne fotografieren wollen, also wurde ein großer schwerer Kran bestellt, der dann diesen Finkling versetzt hat, wo die Heiligendammer den Kopf schüttelten. Die schüttelten in weiteren den Kopf, nicht nur die Heiligendammer, alles rundherum, Wismar Kühlungs, Baun Bad Dobran und so. Die schüttelten des Weiteren den Kopf, als ihnen mitgeteilt wurde, dass sie bitte in dieser und der nächsten Woche nur Mineralwasser aus Flaschen trinken und damit sich auch die Hände waschen und so. Denn das Wasserwerk der Gegend steht kurz vor Heiligendamm, da in der Nähe dieses Waldes, innerhalb des Zaunes. Und der staatlich verordnete Wasserqualitätskontrolleur, der normalerweise jede Stunde kommt, um zu prüfen, ob das Wasserqualität richtig ist, der kommt da nicht mehr rein. Der kann da nur noch einmal pro Tag rein, nicht mehr einmal pro Stunde. Damit kann, können die städtischen Wasserwerke nicht garantieren, dass die Wasserqualität gleichbleibend ist.
Also gibt's nur noch Vitell.
Deckt sich jetzt die ganze Region im örtlichen Supermarkt mit Mineralwasser ein.
Gibt's dann auch ein Trinkgeld für die Anwohner, dass sie sich die Flaschennahrung auch finanzieren können oder müssen die da einfach mit klarkommen?
Ich glaube, sie müssen damit klarkommen. Aber wenn man clever ist, schnappt man sich einen alten Bollerwagen, stellt ihn auf die Straße und verkauft, wie bei der Laffrate, Brause und Mineralwasser am Straßenrand für die Dagebliebenen. Also sehr skurril, sehr merkwürdig und alles, was rundherum wohnt und der Rest der Welt schüttelt einfach nur den Kopf, ob dieses Aufwand, der da betrieben wird. Vor allen Dingen, du läufst die Straße lang und hast das Gefühl, wenn du jetzt deinen Kaugummi-Papier hier wegschnippst, wirst du von einem NASA-Satelliten fotografiert. Woraufhin mein Freund und Mitbegleiter sagte, du wirst nicht fotografiert, wenn du dir dieses Papier wegwirfst, sondern sie wissen schon, dass du das Papier wegwerfen wirst, wenn du den Kaugummi nur an der Tankstelle um die Ecke gekauft hast. Weil sie ja über dich wissen, dass du ein finsterer Geselle bist, der den Mülleimer als solches nicht als...
Insbesondere diese Motorradfahrer.
Ganz genau.
Womit wir übrigens bei deiner Person wären, und da will ich auch noch mal kurz hängen bleiben, weil letztes Mal bist du gar nicht richtig vorgestellt worden. Erstmal hallo Jakob.
Hallo Tim.
Willkommen beim Chaosradio.
Danke schön.
Du hast jetzt hier die Nachfolge angetreten von Holger, der uns leider hat verlassen müssen.
Er hat das, weil da merkwürdige Gerüchte umtaten, er hat das nicht gemacht, weil er irgendwie gehen musste, sondern er schafft es einfach zeitlich nicht mehr.
Genau, er hat nämlich jetzt eine andere Sendung in der Mitte der Woche, und zwar in Frankfurt, und dann ist das alles hier nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres zu erreichen. Das ist natürlich schade, aber so ist es nun mal. Ab und zu haben wir halt dann hier mal wieder einen DJ-Wechsel sozusagen. Ja, insofern, willkommen.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr. Das ist die zweite Sendung bislang. Mir hat es das letzte Mal viel Spaß gemacht. Heute drei neue Gestalten vor meiner Nase. Steini, Tim und Fiedl. Aber ich denke, wir kommen ganz hervorragend klar. Vor allen Dingen auch an euch, die ihr zuhört beim Chaosradio interessiert. Nochmal, es ist keine reine Nerd-Freak-Leute, die mit einem Lötkolben im Bett schlafen, Veranstaltung, sondern es ist höchst spannend. Es geht um Gesellschaft, es geht um Politik und heute geht es um Schrauben. Dinge, die man selber baut. Darum soll es drei Stunden lang gehen. Falls ihr Dinge habt, an denen ihr bastelt oder Dinge schon gebastelt habt, die ihr für besonders beachtenswert erfindet, könnt ihr gerne hier anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Davon berichten oder falls ihr an irgendeinem Projekt gerade steht und damit nicht weiterkommt, gibt es sicherlich den einen oder anderen, der zuhört oder auch von Tim Steini und viele, die hier sind, die vielleicht da auch einen Tipp haben, wo man vielleicht weiterkommt, wenn man da irgendwo an ein Problem rumknabbert.
Genau, der Titel ist nämlich heute Hands-On Hacking, so haben wir das genannt, schön englisch, damit es auch keiner versteht. Und damit es auch überhaupt keiner versteht, haben wir auch noch einen schön komplizierten Untertitel gewählt. Always Yield To The Hands On Imperative, das ist so ein Satz aus der sagenumwobenen Hackerethik, die von vielen Leuten so als Regelwerk angesehen wird, was sie aber nicht ist, sondern es ist mehr so eine, ja wie soll ich sagen, so eine ferne Betrachtung der Hacker-Szene, die versucht zusammenzufassen, was die Hacker-Szene treibt. Und in dem Satz wird halt ganz gut zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass es halt einfach zählt, dass man selber sich die Sachen genau anschaut. Und häufig werden natürlich, nicht ganz so unrecht, so Hacker und sonstige Computerwerke natürlich auch immer primär mit Netzwerken und mit Software und mit Programmierung in Verbindung gebracht. Stimmt natürlich. Aber es gibt eben auch ganz andere Hacker. Es gibt Hacker, die einfach in Hardware bauen. Es gibt natürlich auch die Social Hacker.
Was ist denn Social Hacker?
Social Hacker ist zum Beispiel jemand, der es schafft, von jemanden eine Information zu bekommen, der die eigentlich gar nicht geben möchte. Das notwendige Social Engineering ist halt, wie frage ich, wie gehe ich vor, dass man also einfach diese ganzen Taktiken macht. Also es geht ja beim Hacken immer um das Grenzen ausloten und dann eben im entscheidenden Moment auch um das Überschreiten dieser Grenzen und dann zu gucken, wo es Quiq macht. Und das ist dann im sozialen Bereich nicht anders als bei der Programmierung. Aber eben auch, und das soll unser Thema sein, Hardware, sprich Dinge bauen, neue Geräte schaffen und basteln und einfach auch selber mal zu gucken, was man so machen kann. Weil wir haben ein Phänomen, wenn man sich anschaut, so letzten 10, 15 Jahre, was ist überall aus dem Boden geschossen, überall.
Naja, jede Menge Baumärkte und diese ganzen Baumarkt-Freaks, das sind ja alles Leute, die sind handwerklich wahnsinnig begabt. Und was die zusammenbauen, Schränke, Betten, Zeug, ganze Wochenendhäuser, kriegen die hin, Küchen. Tim baut gerade eine Küche. Und daran kann man deutlich merken, das, was wir jetzt unter Hacking verstehen, ist eigentlich viel einfacher als so eine Küche zu bauen. Da kann man sich obendrein nämlich noch wahnsinnig wehtun und da muss man mit komplizierten Gerätenhand haben. Was den meisten Leuten häufig ein Problem bereitet ist, sie haben halt einfach gar keine Erfahrung mit dieser Mikroelektronik, Lötkolben in Verbindung mit Softwaregeschichte. Und was wir heute mal machen wollen, ist an Beispielen zu zeigen, so hey Leute, in Wirklichkeit ist das eigentlich einfacher. So und jeder, der sich traut, eine Küche zu bauen oder eine Steckdose anzuschließen und so weiter, der kann das hier auch und das Einzige, worauf es ankommt, ist, den Mut zu haben, die Idee zu haben, uns dann nicht beim Kneipengespräch sein zu lassen, sondern es wirklich auch zu machen.
Also sich zum Beispiel drüber zu ärgern, neumodische Autoradios funktionieren ja seit längsten nicht mehr mit Kassetten, sondern wenn du da einen MP3 Player hast oder ganz viel Musik auf deiner Festplatte hast und die gerne im Auto hören möchtest, ist das, was du mitnehmen kannst, ja immer relativ beschränkt. Wieso kann man eigentlich nicht eine 300 Gigabyte Festplatte ins Auto einbauen, da sein Autoradio und einen kleinen Rechner anschließen und dann sagen, ich trag das einfach alles mit mir rum? Solltet ihr sowas schon mal probiert haben, wäre das höchst spannend zu erfahren, ob das funktioniert, wie das funktioniert, wie das aussieht und was ihr da getrieben habt.
Das ist aber jetzt totaler Klassiker, also so irgendwie Zeug ins Auto einbauen ist ja auch so ein lang gehegter Traum.
Der CB-Funker an sich kriegt gerade große Ohren.
Genau, Funk ist ein gutes Beispiel, aber auch ebenso komplexere Sachen. Ich meine, gut, heutzutage hat fast jeder Rechner ein Navigationsgerät drin. Wenn man das vor zehn Jahren haben wollte, muss man schon doch beträchtlichen Aufwand treiben. Hast du eigentlich ein Navigationsgerät in deinem Auto?
Ich hab das immer im Handy, Tim.
Ja, das ist nicht das, was ich meinte.
Nein, ich hab da nichts fest eingebautes drin, das hab ich mal probiert, aber ich hab da nicht so einen Riesen Nutzen von.
Aber es ist halt so ein Trend. Das, was uns täglich umgibt, wird halt auch immer elektronischer. Es hat dann eben auch teilweise interessante Schnittstellen. Und überhaupt ist die ganze Elektronikbranche über die Jahre so weit gereift, dass man eben heutzutage einfach viele Sachen auch so als Pendul bekommt.
Oder viele Dinge haben eine bestimmte Funktion wie ein CD-Player zum Beispiel, aber da kann man ja noch mehr drin machen. Wer von euch jemals ein CD-Player aufgeschraubt hat, wird erschreckt feststellen, da ist nichts drin.
Das ist nur ein Stück Plastik mit irgendwie einem Chip dahinter.
Und da schicken tollen Frontplatte vorne dran. Da könnte man sicherlich hervorragend auch irgendwelche Sachen einbauen und den Raum optimal nutzen, zum Beispiel.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Ja, was könnte man in CD-Player einbauen?
Na, mal los mit den Ideen.
Keine Ahnung. Man könnte zum Beispiel obendrauf ein Display einbauen, auf dem das Video zur aktuellen Musik läuft. Oder du könntest dir in diesen CD-Player obendrauf auf den Deckel parallel noch ein zweites CD-Laufwerk einbauen, wo eine CD die läuft, auf die zweite CD brennt. Oder irgend sowas könnte man ja machen. Es zählt ja quasi nur das Projekt und die Idee, die man dann dazu hat, die mir in diesem Moment fehlt, solltet ihr die haben. Seid ihr herzlichst eingeladen, darüber zu diskutieren. Wir schrauben heute selber und dängeln uns eine neue Erfindung. Blue Moon im Chaosradio 124 auf Fritz unter 0331 70 97 110. Man kann das nicht nur am Telefon machen, sondern es geht auch online, entweder unter fritz.de oder aber im Chaosradio Chat.
Genau, den gibt es nämlich auch noch. Haben wir das schon erwähnt?
Nee, haben wir nicht, deswegen sag ich es ja gerade.
Genau, mitschatten könnt ihr im IRC auf dem FreeNode Netzwerk, also irc.freenode.net und da gibt es ein Kanal Chaosradio und da sind gerade wie viele Leute drin, Charly?
Ich gucke gerade mal immer, 121.
Es ist also richtig was los.
Da kann man auch eine Menge Sachen rausziehen. Mit zwei Dingen werden wir starten. Zum einen mit den Blinky-Lights, dem das die Blink-Lights als Volltrottel geoutet. Und zum anderen, was man vielleicht anschneiden sollte, das ist der heute beginnende Linux-Tag in Berlin am Funkturm in der Messehalle. Der geht bis zum 2. Mai, also bis zum Samstag. Eine Art von Messe für Leute, die sich mit, jetzt helfen wir Tim, freier Software und solchen Dingen beschäftigen.
Genau, eigentlich mit Linux. Der Linux Tag, wie lange gibt es den schon? Ewig. Ist halt so der Versuch gewesen, die Linux-Szene und die Business-Szene. Haben die noch diese selbe Tagline, where.com meets.org oder so? Weiß nicht, ich glaube, die Tagline ist mittlerweile gestorben, aber das war halt so die Idee. Insofern muss ich sagen, haben sie da eigentlich auch sehr erfolgreich gearbeitet, weil der Linux-Tag wird, ja, weiß nicht, wie es jetzt diesmal sein wird, aber ist immer ganz gut besucht gewesen. Das heißt, da laufen mehrere tausend Leute rum. Es gibt halt ein kleines Vortragsprogramm und dann eben viele Stände. Und dann im Anfang war das alles so im Wesentlichen so die Szene, die vor Ort ist. Und dann eben auch Companies, die zum zunehmenden Maße Linux als ein Markt für sich angesehen haben. Also, was weiß ich, IBM setzt ja auch sehr strategisch auf Linux und mittlerweile kann sich eigentlich keine große Company da wirklich mehr machen. Aber ich war noch nicht da, ich will noch hin, aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wie es jetzt hier in Berlin ist. Weil die sind jetzt eben auch nach Berlin gegangen, nachdem sie jahrelang eigentlich in Karlsruhe waren. Dann letztes Jahr irgendwie vor der WM geflohen sind, was ich nicht so ganz verstanden habe. Dann haben sie auch noch den Ort gewechselt nach Wiesbaden. Und jetzt haben sie wohl eingesehen, dass es dann doch vielleicht besser wäre, mal nach Berlin zu gehen.
Wir könnten jetzt über Blinken-Lights richtig?
Genau, Blinken-Lights.
Finger wieder quasi von der Herdplatte genommen. Über Blinken-Lights reden. Vorher, wir haben den ersten Anrufer, und zwar Marius aus Hamburg. Mal gucken, was bei Marius los ist. Hallo, grüß dich.
Moin.
Ja, fantastisch. Woran schraubst du gerade?
Ich schraube gar nicht momentan. Ich habe momentan so einen stinklangweiligen Job 9 to 5. Und ich komme momentan leider nicht dazu, etwas anzunehmen oder beziehungsweise, ich habe zuerst gerade angefangen, den Job, egal. Ich habe da drei Sachen auf dem Herzen. Eins beschäftigt sich zwar mit einem Thema, die anderen Sachen sind so ein bisschen involviert in das Ganze. Okay, erstmal vielen Dank für euer überhaupt über die Jahre lang den Input, sag ich mal, den eure Show jeden Monat liefert und überhaupt die Thematik, womit ihr euch beschäftigt. Für mich ist das sehr beeindruckend und ich weiß auch, sehr weit zu schöpfen, sag ich mal. Was ihr da Monat für Monat, Tag für Tag dran arbeitet und ich finde das nur geil, macht weiter so. Auch an alle da draußen übrigens, weiter so machen. Der zweite Ding ist, wir stehen schon preisgefest für das Camp.
Das Camp werden wir wahrscheinlich demnächst nochmal thematisieren.
Ich weiß es jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Um ein bisschen ausführlicher darauf einzugehen, das waren jetzt zwei Sachen, die du auf dem Herzen hattest. Das Camp machen wir gleich. Was ist das dritte? Du warst ja gar nicht so dramatisch. Ich dachte, du hast jetzt irgendein Riesenproblem.
Ach nein, kein Stück Probleme habe ich nicht. Die Wissen rechnen bei den Psychiater Schwierigkeiten höchstens. Also, das was ich mal gemacht habe in einer Firma, wo ich mal früher gearbeitet habe, war ganz interessant. Da haben wir mit HF-Kabel unter anderem gearbeitet. Und die haben wir kombiniert mit einem AP. Das heißt, wir haben die einfach ein bisschen zweckentfremdet für ganz spezielle Anwendungen. Das war sehr spannend. Mit was hast du das kombiniert? Wir sind von Wave-Lagen, ganz normale Anwendung. Das funkende Signal haben wir einfach mal verstärkt durch so ein HF-Kabel. Und damit ganz zielgerichtet in Lagerhallen, das ganze zielgerichtet eben verschreut das Signal. Ich fand die Thematik damals sehr spannend. Ich war noch sehr jung und das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, muss ich sagen. Ist jetzt nicht so spektakulär, Musik zu geben.
Okay, jetzt kommt die Frage wieder vom Fachidioten. Warum macht man das?
Warum macht man das? Eine Lagerhalle, ganz speziell jetzt auf das Thema anzugehen, ist mit den Hochregallagern extrem schwierig gebaut, die in den Regalen lagert Ware, die meist auch flüssig sein kann. Kosmetiker zum Beispiel. Da wird die Strahlung häufig auch nicht durchgelassen, logischerweise. Also Flüssigkeit verhindert den Durchtrang dieser Ware.
Also um es ganz einfach zu sagen, du stehst irgendwo in der Ecke und hast quasi keinen Handyempfang oder so?
Die Anwendung, ausschließlich ging dann auch auf die Funkscanner für die Ware, um die zu scannen, dass die Mitarbeiter des Lagers sozusagen die Möglichkeit haben, in jedem Quadratzentimeter auch wirklich sicheren Empfang zu haben zu ihren Funkscanner. Das traurige allerdings an der ganzen Geschichte, das war eine sehr, sehr etablierte Firma von diesen Funkscannern, die konnten aber nur WEP-Verschlüsselung.
Also die einfache, längst gehackte, total unsichere Verschlüsselung von Wireless Lager.
Unter einer Minute knackbar, wie ihr das bewiesen habt. Und das fand ich dann wiederum sehr, sehr schade, dass die Anwendung im Endeffekt sehr runtergespielt wurde. Die Installation selbst, die wir übernommen haben, die hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, das war einfach richtig geil. In der hängenden Höhle, sag ich mal, da einfach rum zu burscheln, die Anketten, das Ganze zu befestigen, das war schon wirklich sehr wild. Das Ganze funktioniert 1A. Der Hersteller von den Endgeräten war auch endlos begeistert. Er meinte, so eine Ausstrahlung von Signal hat er ganz weltweit im Lager gesehen. Das geht gar nicht. Und der Betreiber von der Lagerhalle war auch endlos begeistert. Also das Projekt war super, sag ich mal, das hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Okay, super. Zum Camp sagen wir gleich nochmal was. Also das klang jetzt sehr kritisch, war es aber eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe es auch begriffen.
Das Problem mit dem Wireless-Lan, das hatte ich neulich auch auf meiner Party. Ich wollte ganz klug sein und habe so diese Sounddistribution auch über Wireless-Lan gemacht. Und dann kamen dann irgendwann die Gäste und die ganze Wohnung. Die Musik wurde über Wireless-Lan übertragen und wurde dann in jedem Raum mit einzelnen Boxen. Und ich fand das ganz toll. Dann kamen die Leute und die Wohnung voll und die Musik ging aus, weil überall Wasser rumsteint. In Form von Menschen. Ich musste mich dann während der Party beschäftigt, alles wieder auf Verkabelung umzustellen. Was sie im Prinzip gemacht haben, ist einfach die Antennen über normales Fernseh-Antennenkabel zu verlängern. Und dann eben zielgerichtet an die Stellen hinzuspucken, weil es in so einem riesigen Lagern natürlich nicht durchkommt. Schönes Beispiel, man hat halt einfach so ein konkretes Problem. Es geht nicht. Man muss sich dann einfach eine Lösung einfallen lassen, weil es gibt dafür keinen Anbieter.
Du kannst nicht in den Laden gehen und sagen, ich hätte gerne was gekauft. Gibt es nicht. Ja, es war auch ein tatsächlich sehr interessanter Anlass, der sehr interessant zu beobachten war, dass durch dieses Aufkommen dieser Wireless-Lahn-Technologie im Prinzip die Leute mit einem, ja, doch recht esoterischen Problem plötzlich in relativ großer Breite befasst waren, nämlich mit HF und Empfang und Antennen und Sendeleistungs-Ausbeute.
Also HF heißt einfach Hochfrequenz.
Hochfrequenz, genau. Was eigentlich ein Themenkomplex war, denen sich sonst Amateur-Funker oder so, wenn überhaupt, in den 60ern mal sehr intensiv beackert wurde, da Antennen-Selbstbau und Yagi und Reichweitenverlängerung und so eine Geschichten. Plötzlich wurde das eben in die breite Masse der Bevölkerung getragen.
Genau, und bis vor fünf Jahren hätte ich auch noch gedacht, das ist Voodoo-Magic und da muss man sein Leben mit zugebracht haben und 60 sein, um das zu verstehen. Und dann kommt raus ja Pustekuchen, eine Blechdose, ein hinreichend langes Stück Draht, tut's völlig. Und damit kriegt man astreine Antennen und einen super Gewinn hin. Und die sind dann auch noch um Größenordnung billiger, als alles, was man in schlechterer Qualität im Laden kaufen kann. Also hervorragendes Beispiel für solche Do-It-Yourself-Geschichten sind Antennen für WLAN. Wir haben damals ja in Berlin hier auch verschiedene Richtfunksstrecken ausprobiert mit selbst gebastelten Antennen oder mit umfunktionierten Satellitenschüffeln, an die dann halt in den Fokus so eine Antenne, einfach im Prinzip ein mini-kurzer Stummel.
Intelligent gebogene Büroklammer.
Pringles-Dosen gehen auch ganz wunderbar.
Pringles ist nicht das Nonplusultra, habe ich gelernt.
Geht aber schon, oder?
Ja, geht, aber bessere Gewinne kriegt man mit etwas größeren Dosen, mit etwas größerem Durchmesser, also diese typischen... Es gibt die großen Dosen, in denen so Tomaten, hier geschielte Tomaten.
Gastrobedarf sozusagen, die ganz großen Dinger, ja.
Pringles ist ja auch ein Pappkern, der ist nicht wirklich außen taublich. Ach, der weicht durch. Damit hätten wir das erste Thema sozusagen angeschnitten. Ich habe ein Problem, brauche dafür eine Lösung und habe 3, 85 Mark in der Tasche, um das zu klären. Lass dir was einfallen.
Und wo wir gerade bei den Satzschüsseln waren, ein gutes Beispiel von damals. Satzschüsseln waren mal irre teuer und irre kompliziert zu kriegen. Und gab es zwei Ansätze, die wir da ausprobiert hatten. Das eine war ein Regenschirm, der innen mit Alufolie ausgekleidet war. Und dann eben in den Fokus so ein LNB, den konnte man im Laden kaufen. Aber die Schüssel war halt ein bisschen das Problem.
LNB ist der Empfänger?
Der Empfänger, der die Hochfrequenz empfängt. Und die andere Lösung war, einen Bottich mit flüssigem Gips so lange auf dem Plattenspieler im Kreis zu drehen, bis er fest geworden ist. Und dann hatte man eben auch einen Paraboloiden, den konnte man dann eben mit einem Stück Pflaster abziehen, mit Metallzeugs einsprühen oder auch Alufolie machen.
Also nimmst du einfach einen normalen Plastibottich oder was?
Einfach einen Plastibottich und dann schützt du da flüssigen Gips rein. Und wenn du den jetzt in Rotationen versetzt, dann entsteht dadurch ein Paraboloid.
Okay, aber dann hast du ja erst mal nur Gips.
Dann hast du Gips. Wenn der fest ist, machst du davon einen Abzug. Also mit Glasfaser haben wir das gemacht. So normale Glasfaser, laminiert mit Kunstharz.
Das heißt, das gießt man da rein?
Nee, das ist so Gewebe. Da machst du so ein Trennmittel drauf.
So Matten, die werden mit Harz eingeschmiert und dann wird das hart.
Vorher musst du ein Trennmittel drauf machen, sonst kriegst du ihn nicht wieder ab.
Also beim zweiten Versuch hat es geklappt.
Dann machst du dir halt ein Negativ. Und da machst du jetzt eine Folie drauf und laminierst dann auf die Folie drauf. Dann hast du eine total perfekt paraboloide...
Folie ist dann einfach Alufolie?
Alufolie oder irgendwas Metallisches, was gut elektromagnetische Wellen reflektieren.
Und hast original, im Gegensatz zu einer normalen Satellitenschüssel, 350 Euro gespart oder so? Ja, also kostet praktisch nichts.
Aber vor allem der Kick, das selber gemacht zu haben, oder?
Pass auf, wir machen jetzt gleich die Nachrichten. Danach ist Jan dran, der wird was erzählen zum Thema ich baue mir einen Rechner in mein Auto ein, um da die komplette Musik zu haben. Und die Frage, die an euch geht, wir reden ja heute im Chaos Radio über selber machen, schrauben, das Projekt, was man alles so veranstalten kann. Eine ganz spezielle Frage, die mich noch interessieren würde, es klingt ja alles so nach irgendwie, Jungs bauen sich Sachen selber. Stichwort ist Jungs. Mich würde ja interessieren, ob die Mädels von euch, äh, äh, ähnlichen Spaß haben, an Sachen zu bauen, äh, Dinge zu erfinden, irgendwelche Dinge, ähm, sich selbst so zu konstruieren, dass sie genau auf deine Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten sind und nicht einfach doof in den Laden gehen und sagen, guten Tag, ich hätte gerne jetzt meine EC-Karte. Weil das ist langweilig, unsportlich. Und, äh, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt eine Formulierung, wo ihr mir wahrscheinlich den Kopf abhackt, weil heute geht's um Schrauben 2.0.
Und ich mag Gelb, Grün und Rot.
Fritz präsentiert Pink, live in Berlin. Das Eröffnungskonzert zur Internationalen Funkausstellung 2007. Am 30. August ab 18 Uhr im IFA Sommergarten auf dem Messegelände Berlin. Mehr Infos fritz.de Und solang's noch Karten gibt, gibt's Karten überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Zwei nach halb elf. Mit Matthias Karkow.
Bei der Bewachung von Globalisierungskritikern soll die Polizei offenbar Hilfe von der Deutschen Bahn bekommen. Die Süddeutsche Zeitung berichtet, Zugbegleiter in Fernzügen seien angewiesen worden, potenzielle Demonstrantengruppen, die in Richtung Mecklenburg-Vorpommern unterwegs sind, an die Polizei zu melden. Um zu können möglichen Gefahren potenziell frühzeitig und konsequent entgegengewirkt werden, hieß es. Im Potsdam haben etwa 1000 Menschen gegen den G8-Gipfel demonstriert. Sie zogen Richtung Schloss Zezirienhof. Dort hat sich vorher die Außenminister der G8-Staaten getroffen, um den Gipfel in Haigendamm vorzubereiten. Nach Polizeieingaben verlief die Demonstration überwiegend friedlich. Norwegen ist einer Studie zufolge das friedlichste Land der Welt. Schlusslicht ist der Irak. Da steht im Global Peace Index, der erstmals in London veröffentlicht wurde. Der Index listet mehr als 120 Staaten auf. Deutschland kommt in puncto Friedlichkeit auf Platz 12. Die USA liegen auf Rang 96, nur knapp vor dem Iran. Ebenfalls am Ende der Rangliste befinden sich Israel und Russland. Nach einer Meldung vom Sport, Felix Magath wird neuer Sportdirektor und Trainer beim Fußball-Bundesligisten Wolfsburg. Das haben die Niedersachsen nach einer Aufsichtsratssitzung bekannt gegeben. In dieser Nacht anfangs im Berliner Raum und in Ostbrandenburg aufgelockert, nach Westen hingering bewölkt oder klar und überall trocken. Tiefstwerte 10 bis 12 von der Rupine Heide bis zum Elbe-Elster-Kreis 7 bis 9 und auch in Berlin um 9 Grad. Morgen zunächst viel Sonne, später am Tag lockere Quellwolken, aber es bleibt überall trocken bei 20 bis 24 Grad. Wir haben keine Meldungen, wünschen gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Chaosradio 124, Mittwoch 30. Mai 2007. Es geht heute im Chaosradio mit Tim Steining und Fidl vom Chaos Computer Club um Projekte, um Sachen selber bauen, Dinge, die ihr schon mal gebaut habt, Dinge, an denen ihr verzweifelt seid oder Dinge, die ihr als Idee im Kopf habt und die ihr gerne verwirklichen würdet, wozu ihr aber vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Hilfe braucht. Es geht nicht vorrangig um Software. Es geht nicht unbedingt um Programme. Es geht auch nicht nur rein um Computer, sondern es geht um alles, was man in irgendeiner Form selber bauen kann, wenn es dann nicht der Ständer für den heimischen Flachbild-Fernseher ist, weil Besenstielplatte drauf fertig hält, fällt runter, schade drum.
Ja, es sollte schon Piep machen in irgendeiner Form.
Es sollte schon irgendwie den Proveron-Knopf haben.
Ja, man will es ja auch lebendig haben. Roboter sind ja auch ein schönes Thema, so Maschinen, die halt einfach irgendwelche Dienstleistungen für einen erbringen in irgendeiner Form. Wir haben zum Beispiel seit kurzem so einen Roomba.
Ein was?
Ein Roomba. Das ist ein Putzroboter. So ein kleines rundes Teil, ein bisschen größer als ein Plattenspieler, rund, und zehn Zentimeter hoch. Und da drückt man oben auf eine Tasse und sagt Putz mal. Und dann guckt der irgendwie, macht da Düdüdüdüd und dann fährt er einfach los. So lange, bis er irgendwo gegenstößt, dann dreht er sich irgendwie rein zufällig in irgendeine Richtung und dann fährt er halt da lang und die ganze Zeit rotieren unten halt so Putzbürsten und der fegt das irgendwo hin. Genau, und er fegt das so ein bisschen in seinen Magen rein. Dann guckt er da irgendwie eine Weile rum, bis er da irgendwie der Meinung ist, das hätte er wohl alles mal zwei, dreimal abgefahren. Dann piept er nochmal, bleibt einfach stehen. Dann hat man hinten so eine kleine Kamera, nimmt den Staub raus und es ist echt erstaunlich, was das Ding alles so wegmacht. Aber es ist einfach super einfach, super simpel, funktioniert relativ gut und nimmt vor allem auch so einen Staub raus. Also wenn man sich so das Ergebnis anschaut, das kriegt man so mit einem Besen nicht so weggeputzt.
Der ist selber gebaut?
Nee, der ist nicht selber gebaut. Roomba ist ein Produkt, eine Firma und die haben auch verschiedene Modelle und die gibt es dann auch mit Nassreiniger und vor allem seit einiger Zeit auch mit Schnittstelle. Sehr interessant. Also das Ding hat einfach eine serielle Schnittstelle und eine voll dokumentierte Programmiermöglichkeit, sodass man das Ding auch selber programmieren kann. Es gibt seit kurzem sogar ein spezielles Programmierer-Kit. Das ist ein spezieller Roomba, der nicht putzt, aber dafür, ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht so ganz genau, also der kommt halt so komplett mit voller Dokumentation, was ein Programmierer eben zu brauchen. Und dann kann man dann eben auch seine eigenen Algorithmen da implementieren und beliebig ran an die Kiste und die Sensoren auslesen, die Abstandsensoren, die da drin sind. Der ist ganz klug, so der fällt nicht die Treppe runter und der stößt recht intelligent an. Also sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr beherrschbar, sehr einfach zu verstehendes System, wo man eben so robotische Experimente sehr einfach durchführen kann und außerdem macht er sauber.
Also Hausaufgaben machen kann er nicht, aber er kann dir im Zweifelsfall das vergessene Lineal hinterherbringen. Okay, für solche Geschichten und viele andere auch, gibt es ja das Camp, was ihr regelmäßig veranstaltet. Das steht demnächst wieder an. Wir hatten eben schon die Frage, was es denn kostet und wann das stattfindet. Vielleicht könnt ihr ganz kurz was zum Camp erzählen.
Ja, das Camp ist so eine von uns weiterentwickelte Idee, was die Holländer ursprünglich mal hatten, nämlich Hacken im Freien. Und weil das relativ groß ist und viel Aufwand erfordert, gibt es das auch nicht alle Jahre, sondern eigentlich nur alle vier Jahre. Also das ist jetzt das dritte Camp, nachdem wir das erste 99 hatten. Die Holländer machen das schon ein bisschen länger, aber auch alle vier Jahre. Wir wechseln uns dann immer so ein bisschen ab, sodass alle zwei Jahre sowas ist. Und jetzt ist es halt wieder soweit. Wir haben eine sehr schöne Location gefunden in Finofort. Also unweit von Berlin, sind so 50 Kilometer von der Stadtmitte. Da kommt man ganz gut hin.
Sieht 96 aus, ja.
Mit der Autobahn Richtung Stettin, genau. Vierte Ausfahrt. Und dann ist es da auch schon beim Flugplatz Fino. Da gibt es so ein Luftfahrtmuseum, wo noch so viel altes Zeug rumsteht.
Das ist so eine großartige Location. Das ist super, ne? Anderes Thema, da gibt es jedes Jahr ein fantastisches Hot Rod Treffen übrigens.
Stimmt, da sind auch allerlei Automobile. Genau, das sind sowieso schon Veranstaltungen und jetzt eben auch wir. Und das ist super, also mit Bunkern, die können wir dann auch irgendwie alle nutzen. Da kann man also wirklich schicke Sachen machen.
Man kann in einer IL-62, altes russisches Passagierflugzeug, sich vorne ins Cockpit setzen, auf ein Pedal drücken und hinten macht das Leitwerk und kommt rum. Das ist wirklich fantastisch. Wenn ihr jemals in einem Hubschrauber sitzen wollt oder euch mal angucken wollt, wie eine MiG-23 von innen aussieht oder eine alte Passagiermaschine reinkrauchen wollt oder so, da ist das Lufthistorisches Museum Finofort, irgendwie so heißt das, gibt es auch eine Webseite, ist genau der richtige Ort.
Wann findet das statt? 8.30 bis 12. August, also fünf Tage. Wir haben mal mit drei gestartet, sind dann auf vier gegangen und jetzt haben wir eingesehen, so eine Veranstaltung braucht einfach Raum und Luft, weil man will da sowieso eigentlich lange Zeit sein. Viele kommen auch schon deutlich früher. Wann genau man ankommen kann, das steht alles auf unserer Webseite. Aber so die Kernveranstaltungstage sind eben diese fünf, wo dann eben auch ein Vortragsprogramm läuft in den Bunkern. Ich glaube zwei Tracks gibt es. Also so ein bisschen ähnlich auch wie der Kongress im Freien. Aber während der Kongress sehr viel mehr auf diese Vorträge fokussiert ist, geht es hier eigentlich mehr um das Dasein, Leute treffen, campen im Freien und eben auch Hands-On-Projekte. Also sehr viele Leute bringen da traditionell Sachen mit, bauen auch Sachen überhaupt erst vor Ort oder finalisieren sie dort vor Ort.
Und treffen da auch eben eine Menge Leute, die sie noch fragen können oder die sie begeistern können, um zu zeigen, hier schau mal, was wir gemacht haben, was hast du gemacht und spätestens auf dem nächsten Kongress oder dann eben auf dem nächsten Camp oder irgendwo im Internet findet man dann unglaubliche Projekte, die aus den Dingen entstanden sind, die da halt geredet oder ausprobiert wurden.
Genau, wenn er zum Beispiel mal auf Chaosradio.ch geht, da haben wir ja unsere ganzen Podcastkanäle. Einer davon ist Chaos TV. Da gibt es erstens ein Dokumentationsvideo vom letzten Camp, Chaos Communication Camp Dokumentation Video und es gibt auch so eines der letzten Sachen, die wir da gepostet haben, so ein kurzes Video auch von der Location von den Neuen, wo man schon mal so sehen kann, was da alles für cooles Zeug gibt. Das wird auf jeden Fall sehr abenteuerlich und wer Lust hat, da hinzukommen, sollte mal auf events.cdcde gehen. Das ist so unser Blog zu Veranstaltungen. Dort stehen alle Informationen und wichtigen Pointer auch in das Wiki und dort stehen auch die Preise. Das habe ich jetzt gerade nochmal gecheckt, damit ich nichts Falsches erzähle. Also der Regelpreis ist so 150 Euro. Wer früher zahlt, kann sich noch ein bisschen Geld sparen. Für Schüler gibt es noch einen ermäßigten Preis. Das sind dann glaube ich nur 120 Euro. Und wer jetzt viel Geld hat, kann auch ein Business Ticket kaufen, um diese Veranstaltung zu finanzieren, weil das ist alles ganz schöner Aufwand, der da getrieben wird, um da Internet hinzubekommen. Also jeder kriegt Netz in jedes Zelt. Es gibt natürlich WLAN, Pipaponi, nassen Kram, wir haben wieder auch wieder.
Fantastisch. Was es da auf jeden Fall gibt, was man vielleicht wissen sollte für Leute, die so sagen, Höh, Zelten draußen und so, da gibt es einen sehr großen Sanitärbereich mit vielen Duschen und sauren Klos, was nicht bei allen Treffen gegeben ist. Also es gibt keine Dixies oder kaum. Also es gibt richtige Klos mit richtig Wasser. Es gibt eine kleine Bude, wo die Mütter aus dem Dorf Bockwurst, Brause und Kaffee anbieten.
Vor allem, wir bauen da auch noch das Art and Beauty-Wild hin. Also es gibt eine Vielzahl von echt leckeren Food-Ständen. Es gibt Bars, es gibt alles. Es gibt Musik, es gibt DJs, es gibt Pipa-Bohnen. Es gibt noch viele Sachen, die ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen könnt.
Das ganze unter den Tragflächen einer IL-18 oder einer YAK-28.
Genau, unter dem freien. Viele brauchen mal sein Mikrofon.
Dein Mikrofon ist offen, viele. Ich höre mich nicht.
Jetzt ist es offen.
Angeblich kann man da jetzt übrigens gerade auch für 25 Euro die Stunde Panzer fahren. Ja stimmt, da steht ein alter Rollenpanzer. Ob das 25 Euro kostet, weiß ich nicht. Das war der Preis, den mir da jemand erzählt hat. Aber man kann auch quasi als Otto-Normalverbraucher oder Ortilien-Normalverbraucherin hinfahren und sich das einfach so angucken, kostet glaube ich 4 Euro Eintritt.
Und Rundflüge kann man da machen, auch während des Camps. Und es gibt da noch so einen Quadverleih, Quadparcour.
Rundflüge anzubieten, jetzt Leibesvisitation der Fluggäste durchführen. Baust einfach einen großen Zaun oder was auch immer. Okay, also so viel zum Camp, was im August stattfinden wird. Wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, einfach online gucken. Wir machen jetzt weiter im Blue Moon Chaosradio 124. Es geht um Hands-On-Projekte.
Schrauben 2.0 hast du gesagt.
Schrauben 2.0 ist auch sehr schön. Also um Dinge, die man selber baut, um Dinge, an denen man friemelt. Die selbst gebaute Parabolantenne hatten wir schon.
Ich mache noch ein Beispiel.
Wir hatten ganz kurz die Frage, ob wir mit dem Computer in ein Auto einbauen. Da ist Jan am Telefon. Der wartet schon eine Weile.
Dann mal los.
Dann kommt zum Beispiel Steini. Du hast einen Rechner im Auto. Also nicht auf dem Knie, sondern richtig.
Nee, habe ich nicht. Aber ich habe mich damit mal ein bisschen ausführlicher beschäftigt, weil wir das mal geplant hatten. Also mit einem Kumpel zusammen hatte ich das mal geplant. Und da gibt es so ein paar Problematiken, an denen das einfach scheitert. Also da gibt es fertige Sachen im Internet zu kaufen, die aber die gleichen Problematiken mit sich bringen. Also geht erstmal los mit der Festplatte. Die Festplatte einfach ins Auto rein ist halt so ein Problem, weil ist ja alles mechanisch. Das heißt durch die ganzen Erschütterungen lebt die nicht lange. Da gibt es eine Lösung für, das sind jetzt hier Flash-Speicher, so wie es auch im USB-Stick ist. Die entwickeln sie gerade halt auch als Festplatten. Dann gibt es aber das nächste Problem, dass diese Sachen, die ins Auto kommen, sind ja unter diesem Großbegriff Automotive, der dann irgendwie vorschreibt, ich glaube von minus 40 bis 80 Grad müssen die Dinger laufen. Und gut, das mag mit dem Rechner vielleicht noch machbar sein. Das Problem ist, wenn es dann wirklich mal richtig kalt ist und dann mache ich meine Heizung an einem Auto, bildet sich einfach Tauwasser. Was in meiner Elektronik rumläuft. Das heißt, die kann sich natürlich dann auch relativ schnell hochschießen. Und das kriege ich eben auch nicht weg, indem ich irgendwie ein Gehäuse mache, was zu ist, weil das Ding muss ja auch gelüftet werden, der Prozessor. Das heißt, der macht ja Wärme und der muss ja auch gelüftet werden. Insofern glaube ich, gibt es da noch keine adäquate Lösung. Von Leuten, die so ein Ding im Auto haben, habe ich im Internet rausgefunden und gehört, gibt halt diverse Probleme, die Dinger dann nicht hochfahren bei Kälte und so ne Sachen. Und mal abgesehen davon, wer will denn, also wenn ich in mein Auto einsteige, dann will ich Motor an Musik. Und nicht Motor an Windows XP 4.2.
Du musst halt kein Windows XP jetzt sagen.
Du musst halt vorbuchen. Von mir aus auch Linux, aber die brauchen ja alle, um hochzufahren.
Na ja. Da kann man das sicher vorprogrammieren, die Sache mit den Erschütterungen. Ich denke, da kann man im Bootsbau mal gucken. Die hängen ja auch komplette Gasherde so weit kardanisch auf, dass die bis Windstärke acht, dass man da Wasser drauf kochen kann. Und wenn du im Bootsbau schon mal wißt, da gibt es ja auch irgendwelche GPS-Geräte, die bei Windstärke 12 und irgendwie 4 Meterwellen trotzdem funktionieren. Da gibt es sicherlich, sage ich jetzt mal in einer naiven Leichtigkeit, sicherlich irgendwelche Dinge, wo man elektronische Geräte kühlen kann und trotzdem kein Wasser reinkommt.
Die Frage ist, kannst du das auch bezahlen?
Im Zweifelsfall klar, ein Prozessor mit einer Wasserkühlung, sowas gibt es ja auch schon. Es gibt ja alles, aber das größte Problem ist, glaube ich, die Tauwassergeschichte.
Na, die kann man aber tatsächlich konstruktionell lösen. Wie würdest du das machen?
Na, ich würde ein Autoradio-Gehäuse nehmen und alles, was da nicht reingehört, rausschmeißen und stattdessen Mein-Kram reinbauen. Und das ist übrigens auch gar keine dumme Idee, weil das mit dem Radio ist nämlich tatsächlich beim Autoradio eines der größten Probleme. Du kannst ja natürlich irgendeine PC-Radio-Steckkarte nehmen, aber da wirst du genau keine Freude mit haben, weil die funktionieren bei 160 auf der Autobahn wirklich ganz beschissen. Und da machen die in so einem Autoradio wirklich echte Voodoo-Magic, damit das einigermaßen geht. Was man also tut, ist, man besorgt sich auf Ebay oder auf dem Schrott oder irgendwo, und die kosten ja nichts mehr. Diese zwei billige uralt Blaupunkt Düsseldorf, oder wie sie heißen, so ein olles Zeug, und da sind dann so eine kleinen Metallkästchen drin. Das ist der Tuner, und die haben ein wohl definiertes Interface, da muss man mal googeln, da sind dann irgendwie vier oder sechs Adern, und da muss man halt mal rausfinden, wie die funktionieren, dass man da einen Sender einstellen kann. Und dann baut man da eben sein Computer drumrum, vorzugsweise irgendwas, was von sich aus schon ein bisschen robuster ist, also irgendein PDA oder irgendwas.
Aber da muss man ja GZ zahlen für sein Auto.
Muss man doch jetzt sowieso für jeden Rechner.
Spricht im öffentlich-rechtlichen Radio.
Na gut, dann das Tauwasser, was würdest du da machen, Fidel?
Na, man kann es entweder sozusagen gar nicht auftreten lassen, da hat er tatsächlich allerdings recht, dass es dann mit der Belüftung unter Umständen Probleme gibt. Aber Kondenswasser sollte man einfach unten ablaufen lassen.
Aber die Autoradies sind doch auch alle nur Computer.
Die sind auch alle nur offen mit Löchern. Und im Grunde genommen, also entweder behält man die Sachen sozusagen auf Betriebstemperatur, dann bildet sich kein Kondenswasser. Dann hast du sozusagen Vorheizung, genau.
Dann brauche ich auch keinen Rechner mehr, weil das Auto nicht mehr läuft.
Eigentlich eine Batterie einbauen.
Konstruktionell wird so etwas meistens gelöst, indem man die Bildung von Kondenswasser sozusagen zulässt, aber dafür sorgt, dass es unten rausläuft, ohne dass es Schaden anrichtet und gut ist. Also man muss mit diesem Phänomen durchaus leben. Das ist letztlich und endlich, ja, Physik oder wie auch immer man das nennen will. Da kommt man schlecht drum herum.
Es ist nicht so tragisch, wie man gemeinhin glaubt, weil all diese Geräte, die du so bei dir rumträgst, das Handy in der Tasche, das nimmst du bei Klirrkälte aus, da hast du das gleiche Problem. Das ist nicht so irre tragisch. Also solange da nicht gigantische Spannungen anliegen und Ströme fließen, ist das alles nicht so schlimm.
Kondenswasser hat auch den Vorteil, dass es sich dabei meistens um destilliertes Wasser handelt, weil es ja aus Kondensationsprozessen stammt.
Dann leitet es nicht.
Und dann leitet es doch sehr schlecht und diese Kurzschluss- und Signalbeeinflussungsgefahr ist von dem Zeug einfach nicht so groß.
Ansonsten gibt es ja wahrscheinlich auch Leute, die dann eben wirklich einfach eine Menge Musik mitnehmen wollen und nicht unbedingt einen Rechner. Da gibt es ja Autoradis, die direkt einen USB-Anschluss haben für einen Stick. Keine Ahnung, was die da unterstützen. Aber ich meine, einen Stick gibt es mittlerweile auch schon bis 4, 5, 6, 7 GB oder so?
Ja, die unterstützen glaube ich ein ganz normales FAT-Dataisystem, wo dann irgendwelche Ordner mit MP3s drin sind. Und da kannst du dann durchscrollen auf deinem mehr oder weniger groß ausgelegten Display.
Also ich würde sagen, advanced ist dein Gerät dann, wenn du es natürlich auch Internet hat. Wenn du dir noch dein Handy dazu denkst oder holst du ja einfach so bei BASE so eine Flatrate, die gibt es jetzt für 25 Euro auch ohne Telefon im Übrigen. Also für 25 Euro im Monat. Und besorgst du dir für deinen Rechner da drin noch so einen kleinen USB-Adapter, dann kannst du die SIM-Karte direkt reinstecken, dann hat das Ding schon mal ein Netz. Also musst natürlich irgendwie Antenne korrekt rausführen, damit das Ding auch ein bisschen was sieht.
Wunderbar, und dann baue ich einfach noch eine VPN-Verbindung auf zu mir nach Hause auf dem Server und dann kann ich mir die Musik einfach direkt unterladen.
Genau, dann singst du einfach die ganze Zeit dein Auto. Das heißt, du lädst dir was neu auf deinen Rechner, dann wird das irgendwie tröpfchenweise direkt ins Auto gesynkt und du musst da keine blöden OSB-Stacks rein oder rausstecken, sondern du hast einfach immer dasselbe.
Oder du rufst uns zweifelsfall bei Tollcollect an und jedes Mal, wenn du durch eine Mautbrücke fährst, kriegst du eine neue Datei geschickt.
Genau, dann brauchst du noch eine Fernbedienung am Lenkrad, damit du auch während des Fahrens schön mit den Fingern hinter dem Lenkrad rumklickern kannst und spätestens da ist der Zeitpunkt, wo du deinen Windows XP auch wegschmeißen willst, weil du willst die Taster dann auch irgendwie gut anbinden.
Ich dachte, man kann einfach so ein Trackball in den Schaltknauf reinbauen.
Dann hast du die Hand ja nicht erhört.
Dann willst du da irgendwelche Mäuse über den Bildschirm fegen.
Touchscreen wär dann das einzige.
Ach, Touchscreen, dann fährst du gegen Baum.
Also die advanced-este Idee aus dem Chat für das Kondenswasser und thermische Problem war das Gehäuse komplett mit Öl zu füllen. Dass da ja keine Platte drin ist, wenn man eben einen Flaschspeicher nimmt, dann kann man das einfach komplett in Öl betten.
Das machen wir auch einige, das stimmt. Nee, aber irgendwas dickflüssiges, damit wäre auch das Problem einer Erschütterung einigermaßen beschränkt.
Ja, aber wenn wir keine Platte haben, ist das auch egal.
Also ich würd glaub ich Erdnussöl, ah, nee, Sesamöl ranzen.
Das kann man hoch erhitzen.
Sesamöl, warum denn Sesamöl?
Ich glaube Sesamöl wird nicht ranzig. Weiß nicht genau, ob ich jetzt mit Erdnussöl verwechselt, eins von beiden kann man sehr hoch erhitzen. Im Zweifelsfall musst du zwei bauen. Im Zweifelsfall musst du zwei bauen, und dann keine Tests treiben.
Kannst ja auch noch ein paar Kräuter beimischen, dann hast du auch gleich die Raumluft entsprechend.
Gut, wir schweifen ein kleines bisschen ab, aber ich denke wir haben das Problem, Rechner ins Auto einbauen geht nicht. Jetzt insofern zusammengeschraubt, dass wir sagen, es geht einigermaßen doch und hoffen dir geholfen zu haben, Jan.
Genau, wenn du es gebaut hast, schickst du eine Mail an Chaosradio, jetzt hättest du sie sehen.
Damit sind wir beim Thema der heutigen Sendung, Chaosradio auf Fritz 0331, 70 97 110. Nicht nur Jungs, sondern auch Mädels. Es geht um Schrauben 2.0. Was baut ihr denn so? Woran schraubt ihr gerade oder wo denkt ihr? Das hätt ich gerne, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das geht. Darüber haben wir jetzt noch knapp 2 Stunden Zeit, gut 2 Stunden Zeit mit euch zu reden. Fühlt euch frei anzurufen, ihr seid herzlich eingeladen. Ihr könnt auch im Chat mitmachen oder euch auf fritz.de einklicken. Da stehen alle weiteren Geschichten.
Ich komm mit meinem Beispiel.
Du hattest noch eine Idee.
Nee, war keine Idee, war ein Beispiel. Hab ich im Internet mal gefunden, da hab ich natürlich jetzt die URL nicht parat. Da hat jemand aus so einem handelsüblichen Image-Scanner die Scan-Zeile ausgebaut, hat sich überlegt, wie er die dann ansteuert. Das war offensichtlich gar nicht so schwierig. Da kommt irgendwie ein serieller Datenstrom raus oder sowas. Dann hat er aus einer Plexiglas-Röhre oder sowas sich eine ausgesucht, die den richtigen Fokus hatte, hat die sozusagen als längliche Linse da drüber gepackt, hat das dann irgendwie auf sein Dach geschraubt und hat damit wahnsinnig hochauflösend den Himmel über Nacht gescannt. Immer so schreibchenweise, weil sich ja die Erde im Laufe der Zeit so mitdreht.
Also das Ding stand fest sozusagen.
Das Ding steht fest, ist komplett fest montiert auf dem Dach und dadurch, dass sich die Erde dreht, wird jetzt tatsächlich schreibchenweise Nacht für Nacht der Sternenhimmel abgescannt und katalogisiert. Ich hab da Fotos gesehen, das war wirklich outstanding, das war gigantisch hochauflösend. Einfach durch diese langsame Bewegungsstiftung.
Und durch die lange Belichtungszeit wahrscheinlich auch jeder Stern, obwohl es in der City war. Wo stand das Ding in der Stadt?
Das stand da nicht bei. Irgendwie auf dem Dorf. Also das war jetzt nicht in den Stadtbereichen.
In der Stadt macht es ja keinen Sinn wegen dem Streulicht. Oder wenig Sinn.
Na ja, das wär jetzt meine Frage gewesen, ob das so ist.
Nee, ich denke ein bisschen dunkel darf es schon sein.
Ja, das ist ja überhaupt so ein Ding. Es gibt einfach extrem viele Geräte, die so billig verkauft werden, die man super umwandeln kann. Also so einen Scanner in einen Himmelscanner umzubauen, das ist ja schon mal klasse. Was auch sehr beliebt ist, ist Displays aus Geräten auszubauen und daraus sich Projektoren zu bauen. Also Beamer aus, was weiß ich, aus Handys, hab ich da schon mal, gab es auch im Kongress vor x Jahren schon mal, dass einfach so Handy-Displays genommen wurden, mit einer kleinen Lampe dahinter, Kühlung irgendwie noch mit dazu und schon hat man einen billigen Projektor.
Ja, das ist mittlerweile sogar ein richtiger Markt geworden. Man möge einfach mal nur DIY, also Do It Yourself und Beamer in Google eingeben. Da wird man zugemüllt mit Tausenden von Vorschlägen, wie das geht. Und ohne Ende Webshops, wo man sich die Einzelteile kaufen kann, da sind dann so Eisschöpfkellen als Reflektoren, weil man braucht da so was Halbrundes mit Bauscheinwerfern und so weiter. Und da sind Selbstbau-Beamer, die sind auch schon Heimwerkerqualität, eine echte Möbelstücke mit unglaublich guter Qualität. Und das hat letztlich rabiat dazu beigetragen, dass die Preise von Beamern so in Keller geht, weil die Materialkosten für so ein Ding liegen so im Selbstbau bei um die 100, 120 Euro. Und seitdem geht also auch der Markt der Beamer drastisch nach unten, weil das so leicht zu bauen ist. Und da muss man, das ist ein gutes Beispiel, glaube ich, um zu sehen, wie eigentlich aus jeder kommerziellen Idee der liegt so ein Gefrickel zugrunde. Irgendeiner, der mal meinte, ja, das probieren wir mal. Und dann da halt ein Produkt draus gemacht hat aus einer guten Idee. Letztlich in einer kleinen Firma oder irgendwas, und die dann lizenziert und verkauft wurde. Diese ganzen Beamer, die danach auf den Markt kommen, da gibt es jetzt lauter winzig kleine Firmen letztlich, die auch Beamer anbieten, die sowas einfach eben mal zusammengebastelt haben. Also die Vorstellung, dass man das nicht machen kann oder eine gigantische Firma im Rücken braucht, um so eine Entwicklung durchzuziehen, die ist fahrlässig irrtümlich. Und davon möchten wir so ein bisschen abrücken. Man kann fast alles selber machen. Da haben wir im Laufe der Sendung auch noch ganz viele Beispiele. Es gibt kaum mehr einen Bereich. Ich dachte auch immer, oh Gott, das kriegen wir niemals hin. Und dann stellt man irgendwie fest, ne, wir sind jetzt in einem Bereich angekommen, da ist es noch viel einfacher geworden, mit diesen komplexen Dingen zu handhaben. Weil eben ganz viel Werkzeug da ist. Wie früher im Baumarkt. Da gab es die handelsübliche Bohrmaschine, da konnte man auch eine Stichsäge ranmachen und auch eine Kreissäge, das wars. Und heute gibt es 240 verschiedene Spezialwerkzeuge im Baumarkt und jeder weiß damit umzugehen. Und genauso ist es in den anderen Bereichen auch.
Ich weiß, es gibt im Baumarkt schon so Sachen, wo ich überhaupt keine Ahnung habe, wie man das einsetzen könnte.
Aber so ist es eben in allen anderen Bereichen auch. Also es ist zwar mehr geworden, aber unterm Strich tatsächlich einfacher, wenn man sich dann nur auf den Weg macht, zu gucken, was gibt es und wie benutze ich das.
Haben wir denn noch Anrufe eigentlich?
Im Moment nicht. Ich wollte, ich hatte dazu Schrauben 2.0, noch eine zweite Idee, die war die Chaosradio-Hobbytik. Also bevor wir hier weiter über Schrauberei reden, ihr seid herzlichst eingeladen hier anzurufen, mit zu fragen, mit zu diskutieren oder einfach auch nur anzugeben, was ihr dann auf die Beine oder aufs Dach oder sonst wo hingestellt habt. Irgendwelche Dinge, die ihr selber gebaut habt, wo ihr sagt, kaufen ist langweilig, kaufen ist unsportlich, kaufen ist außerdem auch teuer und es fetzt nicht. 0331 70 97 110 mehr Projekte demnächst im Chaosradio. Blumen wir jetzt erstmal ein Stückchen Musik. Supermax ist ein Easy im Mombutica Remix. Übrigens gibt es auch von dieser Sendung wie bei allen anderen von Fritz eine Playliste. Findet ihr wahrscheinlich ab morgen Mittag unter fritz.de online. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt Chaosradio, heute Ausgabe 124 mit Tim und Steini und Fiddle vom CCC. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, herzlich willkommen. Wir machen heute Schrauben 2.0, die CCC-Hobbytik. Es geht um Dinge, die man selber bauen kann oder Dinge an Dinge schraubt.
Hier steht gerade auf diesem komischen Dingsbums, was hier steht, dieses komische Windows-Programm, was hier die ganze Zeit angezeigt wird, steht, Blue Moon in Klammern weiblich.
Das ist ja, das ist, hier das Dingsbums, das Windows-Programm. Ich kann es dir gerne noch mal vorführen, alle einander auch. Heißt, dass die Stimme, die das Wort Blue Moon sagt, weiblich ist. Pass auf.
Das ist Quatsch, die ist männlich.
Ja, Fritz ist männlich immer, aber jetzt. Gibt es auch in der Jungs-Variante bei Sendungen, in denen Mädchen am Publikum sind?
Gibt es auch was Neutrales?
Was gibt es für eine Stimme zwischen Jungs und Mädchen, Tim? Das würde mich jetzt sehr interessieren.
Ich wollte dich nur verwirren.
Siehst du, hat nicht funktioniert. Einige, wo man sich nicht sicher ist. Ewige Weiterphasen, wir fragen mal Nico Ostendahl. Hallo Nico, grüß dich. Ja, uns geht's prima, du hörst ja, wir sitzen um die Werkbank rum und reden über Schrauben und wir freuen uns, wenn du dazu beitragen würdest.
Ja, ich habe auch eine einfache Lösung anzubieten für ein Problem, was ich hatte oder was ich immer noch habe. Und zwar habe ich eine Terrasse gebaut, alles gut und schön, jetzt möchte ich dort Musik hören.
Stellst du einen Rekorder raus?
Ja, aber ich habe eine hochwertige Anlage im Haus und die hat viele Funktionen, die ich draußen nutzen möchte. Ich möchte sie nicht mit rausschleppen, also habe ich draußen ein paar billige Boxen angehangen. Zwar musste ich dafür ein paar Drähte ziehen, aber um die vollständig bedienen zu können, konnte ich ja die Fernbedienung schlecht nutzen, durch Wände funktioniert die nicht. Also habe ich mir so ein Lichtleiterkabel zusammengefriemelt und damit funktioniert das.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt eine Fernbedienung mit Kabel wie 1985 am Fernseher?
Nein, nicht mit Kabel, ich habe dieses Lichtleiterkabel nur durch die Wände durchgezogen und draußen wie so ein Auge.
Ach so, alles klar.
Draußen leuchtest du mit der Fernbedienung also auf die Richtung Lichtleiterkabel und innen terminiert der dann an dem Infraroteempfänger der Stereoanlage.
Nein, gar keine Linse.
Einfach nur so.
Mit Kleber gleiche Macht praktisch.
Funktioniert als ein Passivsystem bei dir? Da hast du Glück gehabt tatsächlich. Also ich kenne genau diese Geschichte als aktive Lösung sozusagen, wo du noch, ja, brauchen wir halt noch so ein Steckernetzteilchen.
Ich habe es ja deshalb gemacht, weil es so einfach war, aber nun möchte ich das über eine weitere Distanz machen, aber da funktioniert es nicht mal mehr. Da wollte ich vielleicht mal wissen, wo man vielleicht irgendwie ein hochwertigeres optisches Gabel herbekommt.
Naja, viel einfacher ist, du baust draußen einen Infraroteempfänger, also einen elektrischen, der wie er in deinem Gerät ist, eine Infraroteempfangsdiode, da ein klein bisschen Logik dahinter, wenn es überhaupt nötig ist. Ist nicht nötig. Wahrscheinlich, aber ein bisschen verstärken würde es wohl schon.
Ein bisschen flanken willst du wieder rausholen, aber...
Und dann das elektrische Signal über das Kabel nach drinnen übertragen, innen wieder eine Infrarotesendediode vor deinem HiFi-Gerät und das löst das Problem ebenso gut. Also mit Googles Hilfe löst man dieses Problem, ich schätze in 10 Minuten.
Da gibt es tatsächlich auch ein fertiges Produkt für.
Ja, also das wäre auf jeden Fall auch der Ansatz, den ich vorgeschlagen hätte. Erstmal so ein Empfänger und ein Sender koppeln. Dann empfängst du das sozusagen schon mal da, wo du sendest und dann sendest du es da, wo du es empfängst.
Wir haben dieses optische Kabel eigentlich noch selber zusammengebastelt aus so einer Pilzlampe.
Nein, echt? Das gibt aber zwei extra Punkte für Kreativität. Super.
Naja, die Lampe hatte ich, die war hässlich. Also habe ich die Borsten rausgezogen und da auch ein Kabel gemacht.
Nico, du hast vor allem eine spitzen Idee entwickelt zum Thema schöner Wohnen. Wie kann man diese Pilzlampen verwenden? Unauffällig in der Wand verschwinden lassen. Ohne sie wegzuschmeißen. Kann man eigentlich auch irgendwas Kreatives aus einer Lava-Lampe bauen? Die sind ja auch fürchterlich.
Was? Lava-Lampen sind cool.
Man kann da neue Soße reinfüllen, dann sind die ganz schick.
Übrigens, apropos Lava-Lampe, man kann mal Do-It-Yourself und Lava-Lampe eingeben. Es gibt eine Menge Selbstbauprojekte für Lava-Lampen, unterschiedlichster Couleur. Total coole Geschichten, die da Leute...
Nur, dass die Wohnung nach Bittermandeln steht, zwei Wochen lang.
Fidel hat es ausprobiert, der steht auch auf Lava-Lampe. Auch möglich. Ich wollte kurz nochmal zurück zu dem Glasfaser. Und zwar habe ich gerade, just heute Mittag, per Zufall in MDR einfach genial, gesehen, den Beitrag über durchsichtigen Beton.
Hab ich auch gesehen.
Da wird also Glasfasergewebe in den Beton mit eingebaut, eigentlich, um ihn zu stabilisieren. Und wenn man das richtig macht, in irgendeiner Netzform, dann leuchtet da Licht durch. Und man sieht sogar Schatten von Leuten, die dahinter langlaufen.
Du hast eine Wand, wo man durchgucken kann?
Genau, eine Betonwand, durch die du durchgucken kannst.
Das wäre auch vielleicht auch was für deine Fernbedienung. Man muss da nur gucken, dass es vielleicht nicht die Wand zum Klo oder zum Schlafzimmer ist. Und die Nachbarn sagen, viele hast du heute nur zwei Minuten Zähne geputzt.
Aber wenn du diese Wand hast, hast du unter Umständen ein anderes Problem. Es gibt ja dieses schöne Gerät, dieses TV-Bigorn. Das ist so ein kleines Gerät für einen Schlüsselanhänger, was alle Aussequenzen für alle Fernseher auf diesem Planeten hat. Und wenn du dann so eine Wand hast und es kommt jemand vorbei, oder auch auf deiner Veranda, muss dich nicht wundern, wenn deine Stereo-Anlage die ganze Zeit ausgeschaltet wird, weil sich dann so ein Teil geschoppt hat.
Das ist übrigens auch so ein Bastelprojekt, dieses TV-Bigorn. Das ist genau aus sowas entstanden, dass sich mal jemand gedacht hat, Scheiße, einfach alle Standard-Ausschaltsignale mal in ein Chip brutzeln und dann per Infrarot-Sendediode um sich pusten.
Super, bei Saturn oder so, da kannst du echt Probleme auslösen. Du drückst einfach auf die Taste.
Auf irgendeiner Messe.
30 Sekunden später ist einfach mal alles aus und die Verkäufer werden ganz unruhig.
Oder wenn du durch irgendeine Messe läufst, dann haben die ja häufig da nicht mal die Fernbedienung greifbar und kriegen das nicht wieder eingeschaltet. Aber das ist ein gutes Beispiel, wie man sowas eben auch in Kleinserie mal bauen kann. Das ist von der Elektronik her einfach und sowas jetzt mal zu Layouten, da muss man sich ein bisschen mit Eagle-Layout-Software mal beschäftigen. Das ist so ein Programm zum Entflechten der Leiterbahn auf so einer Platine. Das klingt irre kompliziert, ist es aber nicht. Also jeder, der irgendwie mal eine Skizze für sein Regal gemacht hat, der kommt damit am Ende irgendwie auch klar. Das schickt man dann zu PCB-Pool oder ähnlichen Anbietern und kriegt ein paar Tage später die fertige Platine wieder. Da lödet man die Bauteile drauf. Die kann man jetzt, wenn man viele machen will, auch noch bestücken lassen. Das heißt, es ist für einen Aufwand, ich schätze mal von unter 1000 Euro möglich, 500 von solchen Geräten fertigen zu lassen und dann auf einer Website anzubieten oder so. Also nur für die Machbarkeit solcher Projekte. Das ist tatsächlich nicht so schwierig, wie es immer aussieht. Und man braucht keine große Firma sein, um kleine elektronische Spielereien auch in das Volk zu bringen.
Nico, haben wir dir da geholfen mit deiner Firmament-Bedienungsproblematik?
Ja, natürlich.
Sender, Empfänger, Empfänger-Sender funktioniert?
Ja, aber ich werde mir jetzt noch ein paar Lava-Lampen kaufen und dann werde ich mal sehen, ob ich da Fische züchten kann.
Probier es erst mal mit Plastikfischen. Plastikfische ist sowieso besser, die musst du nämlich nicht füttern und da muss man es auch nicht sauber machen.
Ja, aber die müssen sich dann wenigstens bewegen.
Und drüben schüttelst du die einfach ein bisschen.
Außerdem werde ich mal ein Loch zum Nachbarn bauen und mal sehen, ob ich den Fernseher dort aufbedienen kann dann.
Also so Fischroboter sind bestimmt auch was ganz Putziges. Die muss man auch nicht füttern und die kann man natürlich ja noch richtig schön fernsteuern.
Aber die müssen immer an die Ladestation und man muss die quasi doch füttern.
Ja, aber dann können sie ja selber hin schwimmen.
Hattest du nicht mal einen Hai? Ja, der hängt gerade am Akku.
Dieser Roomba zum Beispiel, der lädt sich auch selber auf. Immer wenn der Akku abgegeht.
Dein automatischer Staubsauger.
Genau, der Staubsauger. Der läuft dann einfach zu seiner Dockingstation und nähert sich dann sozusagen wieder an der Muttermilch und zieht dann weiter.
Was kostet so ein Ding? Zu teuer.
Das geht so bei 250 Euro oder so los, aber es ist echt praktisch. Also vor allem, wenn man so Räume hat, die so dealen, ist super. Auf der Fläche ist es schwierig.
Und vor allem, wenn du irgendeinen lethargischen Hund oder eine Katze zu Hause hast, die einfach ein bisschen Bewegung braucht.
Genau, es gibt sogar eine spezielle Version für Katzenhaare und Hundehaare.
Nee, ich meine, du kannst der Katze sozusagen so einen Spielkameraden geben, dass sie nicht doof vor der Fensterbank rumliegt, sondern die ganze Nacht hinterher rennt.
Ja, also wenn ein Tier Animationen braucht, kann man sich da aber auch mit so automatischem Laser-Zielkanon sicherlich ein bisschen Spaß haben.
Chaosradio 123, die Chaosradio 124. Entschuldigung, die Chaosradio Hobbytech Schrauben 2.0. Nico, danke für deinen Anruf. Nächster am Telefon ist Tec aus Berlin. Hallo Tec, grüß dich. Woran schraubst du gerade?
Ich wollte von meinem kleinen Projekt mit meinem Network Storage Link erzählen, von Linksys. Und zwar ist es ja im Prinzip so ein Network Attached Storage Gerät für Festplatten am Laden. Und man kann da halt auch so schöne Spiele reinmachen, wie komplettes Stabien drauf laufen lassen, vom USB Stick oder von einer Festplatte. Und ich hab mir da einen kleinen Media Player draus gebastelt, wo ich dann halt meine MP3s über das Netzwerk streamen kann oder halt vom Stick für mir anhören kann.
Also noch kurz zu den Leuten, worum es geht. Network Attached Storage sind so kleine Geräte, die im Prinzip nur eine Festplatte mit ein bisschen, mit einem Ethernet-Port sind oder ist da jetzt mit Wireless schon?
Meinst du, das ist das normale NSS-U2 mit LAN-Anschluss?
Genau, also da steckt man einfach ein Ethernet-Kabel ein, wie man es in den Rechner auch machen wollte, bloß dieser Rechner besteht eigentlich nur aus der Festplatte und bedient dann so die gängigen Netzwerkprotokolle, dass man den halt an seinen Rechner so mounten kann. Und was hast du da jetzt genau gemacht?
Also ich hab mir dann einen Gigabit USB Stick halt hinten dran, hat ja zwei USB-2 Ports und da halt einen Debian Linux drauf installiert und der bootet halt ganz normal in das Linux. Und da kann ich halt alles mitmachen, mit allen Abpaketquellen, die ich halt haben möchte, drauf installieren und die laufen auch alle.
Also du bootest quasi, du ignorierst die Software, die da drauf ist, bootest das Ding von der eigenen Software? Und wie kommt dann die Musik daraus?
Also ich hab halt einmal über USB den Stick, wo von da bootet, da hab ich halt noch ein bisschen Platz drauf, da kann man halt ja MP3-Files mit drauf spielen oder halt extra noch eine Festplatte mountain oder so.
Aber wo kommt die Musik raus?
Ey, die kommt auch in eine USB-Soundkarte raus. Das ist nur creative und rangeschlöpft, der Alza-Treiber war schon drauf und läuft von Affe an die Paare.
Aber warum musst du denn die Musik auf den USB-Stick tun? Du hast doch da schon die Festplatte.
Das wollt ich auch mal fragen.
Man kann sich das aussuchen. Also man kann jetzt auch noch einen Datentrigger mountainen, den man halt möchte oder halt per Stream übers Netzwerk. Und halt ein bisschen rumgespielt hab ich halt auch noch mit der Kiste, halt einen GPS mal dran gedongelt. Jetzt bin ich gerade noch dabei, mir ein LCD-Display ran zu frickeln, dass ich das Ding auch irgendwie ein bisschen convenient bedienen kann.
Warte mal, Tek, eine ganz kurze Frage. Hast du eine Freundin oder sonst irgendwie sozialen Kontakt? Oder lebst du da mit deinen Drähten und Kabeln für dich allein?
Nicht nur, ich bin Waldorf-Fühler.
Okay, meine Frage jetzt. Warum machst du sowas? Also einfach nur, worüber wir heute reden, der sportliche Anreiz, etwas zu machen, was Leute nicht machen.
Also während sich die Industrie jetzt Mühe gegeben hat, den Computer aus diesem Gerät zu extrahieren, fügst du ihn jetzt wieder hinzu?
Es ist einfach Spaß und eine Freude. Die Dinger sind ja so billig geworden, da kann man einfach ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät haben.
Was kosten die jetzt?
Für den Steutschling habe ich als Gebrauchtgerät 70 Euro bezahlt.
Wie groß ist die Platte?
Ich habe eine extra USB Platte mit 500GB dran.
Aber wenn du das Gerät jetzt kaufst, ist das doch schon eine Platte mit drin?
Nee, das ist nur eine Plastik Schachtel.
Das ist ein bisschen größer als eine Zigaretten Schachtel. Und da ist keine Platte dran. Was da dran hat, ist zwei LAN und zwei USB 2-Ports.
Und zwei grüne Lampen, glaube ich.
Ich dachte, das wäre so ein Ding, wo gleich die Festplatte mit drin ist.
Die gibt es auch, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es von links direkt schon welche von der Sorte gibt.
Gibt von mir so einen Firmen, aber da ist ja die Hackvalue nicht so groß, weil da kann man die Firmenwerde nicht so einfach umflaschen. Du lebt ja der Mensch von seinen Herausforderungen genauso wie im Sport. Jetzt hast du das fertig, was kommt als nächstes?
Genau, als nächstes habe ich mir schon überlegt, so eine Kiste gut als KPC zu nutzen. Ich meine, ein kleines LCD-Player ran, ein paar Knöchchen zu benutzen und Auto.
Das ist auch die Kondenswasserproblematik nicht so groß und nicht so viele Metallteile dabei.
Und nichts Bewegliches vor allem.
Super Plan, Tech, dann wünsche ich dir viel Glück bei allem, was du immer anfassen wirst und niemals in eine Steckdose fassen.
Das meine ich, aber das ist schon eine Amme noch.
Das ist so ein bisschen Schrauben 2.1. Wenn man jetzt schon anfängt, ein Linus-Betriebssystem dann selber zu konfigurieren, dann steht einem natürlich irgendwie alles offen. Das ist das schöne an Linus, da kann man nun wirklich vor allem für jeden Scheiß und auch noch wirklich für die älteste Schrotthardware Treiber finden. Sodass man also auch wirklich Sachen, die man super billig bekommt, die man wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr kaufen muss, weil die einfach so am Straßenrand stehen, weil sie irgendjemand loswerden möchte, zum Einsatz bringen.
Du hast gerade von TV-Gon gesprochen, Alex aus Potsdam hat angerufen, hat eine Frage dazu. Hallo Alex. Wie können wir dir denn helfen? Was für ein Teil?
So ein TV-Gon?
Du kannst so einen TV-Gon selber bauen. Das ist überhaupt nicht kompliziert. Das ist im wesentlichen Fall, wie du etwa sagst, ein PIC-Mikrocontroller und ein paar Infrarotioden. Wo ich mir jetzt nicht genau sicher bin, ist, wie schwierig, schrägstrich einfach es ist, an all diese Ausschaltcodes der Fernseher ranzukommen. Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob der Mann, der die gebaut hat, die publiziert hat oder nicht. Aber meines Wissens hat er die publiziert. Und er hat auf dem letzten Chaos-Kongress einen Vortrag erhalten. Und da dürftest du in unseren Webseiten vom letzten Kongress ein bisschen Dokumentationen dazu finden und auch den Vortrag als Videodatei dir angucken können. Also der Selbstbau von dieser Geschichte ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich einfach. Das sind Teile, ich glaube, der teuerste waren die beiden Batterien, die man dazu benötigt. Irgendwie hatte er das mit zwei Batterien designt, so ein Knopfzellenbatterien. Das waren glaube ich die teuersten Teile mit, die da beteiligt waren.
Man kann die Dinge auch selbstlernend machen, weil in dem Moment, wo du da so einen Infrarot-Dingsbums hast, kannst du ja in der Regel auch empfangen. Das heißt, du stellst das Ding einfach in so einen Lernmodus. Das macht ja heutzutage auch schon jede, gibt ja diese Komfort Fernbedienung, die kann man sich auch programmieren. Da drückt man auf eine Tasse, dann wartet die einfach, was von vorne reingeflossen kommt. Das heißt, man nimmt einfach irgendeinen Fernseher, der rum ist, drückt auf die Austasse, lernt das sozusagen, das eigene Gerät und schon kann er wieder einen mehr.
Also diese TV-Bigan ist im Prinzip eigentlich auch so in der jetzt erhältlichen oder, glaube ich, mittlerweile wieder ausverkauften kommerziellen Form eigentlich ja auch wirklich nur so ein Selbstbauprojekt. Der Typ hatte diese Idee, ja, man müsste ja mal, ist hergegangen, hat all diese Ausschaltkurz gesammelt, hat es da in diesen kleinen schwarzen Käfer reinprogrammiert und ist dann bei seinen Freunden damit irgendwie Schabernack treiben gegangen. Und die haben alle gesagt, nicht, komm nie wieder zu mich besuchen, sondern ich will auch so ein Ding. Und ja, das hat er sich sozusagen als Ansporn genommen, wirklich den Heißkleber und die Kabelbinder irgendwie wegzudesignen und hat das wohl irgendwie in Taiwan oder sonst wo einfach produzieren lassen.
Mitch Altman heißt er.
Mitch Altman heißt er, genau. Und wie hieß der Vortrag? Wie hieß der Vortrag?
Im Zweifelsfall könnt ihr, wenn ihr am Radio gerade sitzt und denkt, das ist eine Spitzenidee, so ein automatischer Ausschalter, chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es eine Suchfunktion oder da kann man auch weiter suchen, wenn man sich dafür interessiert. Nicht?
Ich habe hier auch keine Ahnung.
Der Vortrag hieß, TV begann, better living through inventing.
Genau.
Gibt es alle.
Gibt es so wiederum auf den Seiten das Chaos Communication Congress.
Nee, gibt es auch auf Chaos Radio.
Gibt es auch auf Chaos Radio. Also gibt es überall. Gibt es überall.
Gibt es auf jeden Fall im Internet.
Auch in ihrem Google. Ja, habe ich gefunden. Alex, wir hoffen geholfen zu haben.
Ja, und ich habe hier gleich sowas gefunden, womit man das auch in ein Handy einbauen kann. Weil der doch noch auffälliger ist.
Viel Spaß beim Basteln. Aufschrauben, reinschrauben, Garantie verloren. Das weißt du selber. 0331 70 97 110 Chaos Radio 124 im Blue Moon heute auf Fritz. Noch bis eins. Und wir reden heute über Dinge, die man sehen kann. Und wir reden heute über Dinge, die man sehen kann. Die man selber bauen muss und die man selber bauen möchte. Wenn ihr da irgendwo verreckt seid bei irgendeinem Projekt und ihr kommt nicht weiter oder ihr habt irgendwas geschraubt und wollt darüber berichten, dann ist das genau diese Sendung, wo ihr anrufen könnt oder mitmachen könnt, auch im Chat. Gerne auch Mädels, das wäre interessant, woran ihr da im Moment bastelt. Wir hatten ganz am Anfang, vor einer Stunde fast das Thema Blinkenlights. Das ist korrekt. Das war das Haus des Lehrers Alexanderplatz. Lampe an, Lampe aus, Lampe an, Lampe aus, immer in einem anderen Stockwerk und die Leute stehen da vor uns und sagen, oh.
Hast du das gesehen eigentlich? Ja klar.
Ich musste da jeden Tag vorbei. Ich fand es spannend und stand da und dachte, wer macht das? Was ist das? Wie funktioniert das? Und wenn ich nicht weiß, finde ich trotzdem eine spitzen Idee.
Das war ihr. Das war ganz einfach. Wir haben da mit 60 Leuten gestanden, jeder an dem Licht schallt.
Ist klar. Mich hat mal jemand gefragt, wozu man sowas braucht.
Ja, braucht man nicht. Und was hast du dir gedacht, wie es funktioniert?
Keine Ahnung. Also ich dachte, es gibt, ich bin ja auch nicht richtig...
Nimm mal doch mal an, du stehst vor so einem Haus.
Ich stehe vor dem Haus und es ist ein Haus des Lehrers. 24 Stockwerke, 23 Stockwerke, irgendwie so groß.
Na ja, es sind so 13.
13. Ich bin so relativ klein, für mich sind es 23.
In den oberen acht Blinken.
So und in jedem Zimmer geht die Lampe aus, dann irgendwo in die zweite Etage weiter drunter, geht wieder eine Lampe an, dann geht die wieder aus, ist eine Etage oben drüber wieder an. Scheinbar zufällig und du denkst im ersten Moment, da stehen wirklich Leute, machen sie Licht an und aus. Nach einer halben Stunde, es war auch wie auch hundekalt, also länger hat man auf dem Alex-Ani ausgehalten, dann werden da doch nicht Leute rumstehen. Und dann dachte ich mir, da hat irgendjemand einen Stecker reingesteckt, all diese Lampen, irgendwie, da gab es ja irgendwo eine Schalltafel, angezapft, das Ding in einen Rechner geschoben und dem Rechner gesagt, du schaltest jetzt rein zufällig die Lampen an und aus. Ihr habt es gemacht, wie hat es funktioniert? Im Wesentlichen so, nur dass die Funktion reiner Zufall eigentlich nicht vorkam, sondern da wurde noch ein Programm geschrieben, was den Leuten da draußen die Macht gegeben hat, ihre eigenen Zufälle zu erzeugen.
Das ist ja erst der zweite Schritt. Erstmal muss man sich natürlich überlegen, wie kriegt man das Licht in das Fenster? Also um vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammenzufassen, Blinkenlights war das Projekt, was 2001 am 11. September eingeschaltet wurde und im Februar danach im 2002 wieder aus. Also knapp sechs Monate lief das. Und die obersten acht Etagen waren so beleuchtet, dass jedes Fenster zum Pixel wurde. Da hatte man eben so einen Bildschirm. Wir hatten eben so die Idee gehabt vorher, weil eigentlich wollten wir ja eine Party machen, 20 Jahre CCC, la la la. Und die Party haben wir dann nebenan gemacht. Dann stand dieses Haushalt so dunkel da rum und wir dachten uns, was machen wir denn da drauf? So und dann wurde eben diese Idee geboren, da vielleicht auch mal Bilder anzeigen zu können. Dann war man relativ schnell zu dem Wunsch, eben auch ein interaktives Spiel darauf eingehen zu können.
Eigentlich war es glaube ich, begann es wie viele Dinge mit einem Anruf, die glaube ich die Frage beinhalten, was muss man tun, um Tetris auf dem Haus zu spielen? Ich glaube, das war die Ursprungsintention.
Die erste Idee war da halt, was drauf zu schreiben. Die erste Reaktion auf diese Idee war, naja, dann kann man ja auch gleich Tetris drauf spielen. Und dann kam dieser besagte Anruf hier auch immer. Auf jeden Fall fand sich dann in halb kürzester Zeit ein Team, was sich um einen Tisch gesellte. Und dann wurde einfach darüber nachgedacht, was in aller Welt muss man tun, um das möglich zu machen und zwar so, dass man es auch noch bezahlen kann. Na ja, und da haben wir uns dann eben was ausgedacht, was am Ende auch ganz gut funktioniert hat. Und es war alles Standard-Baumarkt und billigheimer Technologie, die man eben bei Konrad und bei Obi sich zusammen kaufen kann. Erst mal ein paar Ständer gebaut aus Dachlatten, ganz normale Baustrahler dran gehängt, an jeden Baustrahler unten an der Strippe ein Relais, sodass man das Ding eben an- und ausschalten kann, so richtig schön mechanisch mit Klack Klack. Und dann gingen eben viele kleine Kabels von diesen Relais in die...
Auf den Tisch, die gingen erstmal auf den Tisch.
Genau, da gab es so einen Tisch und da führten dann irgendwie so unzählige Kabel hin und wurden dann auf diesem Tisch mehr oder weniger direkt drauf miteinander verlötet.
Viel Heißkleber.
Viel Heißkleber, genau. Und das sah alles ganz... Diese ganze Installation sah nicht so aus, als ob sie überhaupt funktionieren könnte, geschweige denn...
Oder einem großen Knall einmal funktioniert.
Genau. So, und dahinter war dann einfach ein Rechner, der mit so Steckkarten über die notwendigen IOPorts ausgerüstet wurde. Also sozusagen jede einzelne Leitung separat mit einem Du-Bist-An- oder Du-Bist-Aus-Signal versorgen kann. Und dahinter wiederum Software, relativ einfach gestrickt, die halt im Prinzip dieses abstrakte Modell eines Bildschirms auf diese Leitung umgesetzt hat. Also Pixel links oben in dem Bild ist letzten Endes Etage 12, Fenster 1. Ganz simpel. Und dann geht es halt an und aus. War eigentlich wirklich kein Big Deal, es wurde dann halt ein bisschen pfiffiger dadurch, dass wir an diesen Computer dann noch einen anderen Computer rangefrummelt haben, der war über eine ISDN-Telefonleitung mit dem Telefonnetz verbunden, sodass man eben auch anrufen konnte bei diesem Rechner, das heißt der Rechner war in der Lage festzustellen, da kommt ein Telefonanruf, dann hat er den angenommen und dann war er auch in der Lage diese Tontasten auf. Dem Telefon, also diese DTMF-Töne, wie sie so schön heißen, zu analysieren. Sodass man eben mit den Tasten direkt gucken kann, an diesem Rechner, in dem Fall war es halt das Spiel Pong, sodass man eben angerufen hat, dann ging das Spiel Pong los, links ein Schläger, rechts ein Schläger, dazwischen der Ball, der immer hin und her geht und dann spielte man eben gegen den Computer und wenn noch einer angerufen hat, dann haben eben zwei miteinander.
Es stehen zwei Leute an der Straßenunhaltestelle und spielen auf dem Hochhaus gegenüber Pong, großartig. Auf dem Fernsehturm war die Aussicht noch etwas besser.
Das war Blinkenleids und dann kamen halt so Leute und dann so irgendwie, ja, wie kommt man denn überhaupt auf so eine Idee? Wie kommt man denn auf so eine Idee nicht? Es war für uns so vollkommen selbstverständlich eigentlich, dass man diesen Gedanken dann mit dem Haus pixeln. Also das war ja auch, muss man dazu sagen, nicht das erste Mal, dass so eine Matrix auf einem Haus erschien. Das haben andere schon vorher gemacht, schon Jahre vorher. Was neu war bei Blinkenleids, in dem Sinne war eigentlich nur diese Sache, mit dem Telefon das zu verbinden. Und dadurch wurde es halt für die Leute einfach greifbarer. Sie konnten dieses Telefon in die Hand nehmen, sie konnten eine einfache Telefonnummer anwählen und auf einmal änderte sich alles. Sie merkten einfach, sie sind direkt mit diesem System im Kontakt und das ist jetzt ihr Ding. Und dann haben sie eben auch gespielt, wie die Blöden.
Blinkenleids, Schrauben 2.0, die Chaosradio-Hobbytik. Heute hier auf Fritzen noch eineinhalb Stunden, 0331 70 97 110. Sollte die ähnliche Dinge veranstaltet haben oder vorhaben, das zu machen, das ist genau der Punkt, wo man fragen kann, prahlen kann, oder aber auch sagen kann, ich komme hier nicht weiter, so ihr denn Fragen habt. Am Telefon ist Pascal aus Berlin. Hallo Pascal, grüß dich.
Hallo.
Wie können wir dir denn helfen?
Also ich hab das Problem gehabt, dass ich überlegt habe, ich will mir auch ein kleines Gerät bauen, also was jetzt war, tut nicht so viel zur Sache. Aber dazu hätte auch irgendwie eine Leiterplatte gehört und ein paar Bauteile drauf gelötet. Und da dachte ich mir, das könnte man eigentlich auch für ein paar Euro verkaufen und ein bisschen Geld damit verdienen, so nebenbei, neben meinem Studium. Und dann ist mir eingefallen, dass es dieses blöde Elektrogerätegesetz gibt, also was ja eigentlich gar nicht so blöd ist, weil es die Umwelt schützt und so. Aber da muss auch jemand, der eine kleine Anzahl von Elektrogeräten herstellt, muss sich bei der EAR anmelden und damit halt seine Entsorgungskosten für diese Elektrogeräte bezahlen.
Wenn du sie sozusagen in kommerzieller kaufmännischer Absicht verkaufen willst, dann damit Gewinnerzielung machst.
Das mach ich ja, wenn ich so herstelle und dann so verkaufe, dass ich Geld damit verdiene.
Das hält auch ein bisschen davon ab, in welcher Form du sie darbietest, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Platine anbietest, die als Bastelsatz deklariert ist, dann fällst du da nicht unter irgendwelche Geräteverordnungen, sondern du hast da einen Bastelsatz zum Zusammenbauen. Und ich glaube, es ist auch ein bisschen quantitätsabhängig, wie viele Stückzahlen du da gedenkst umzusetzen. Also ich glaube, wenn man sich da noch ein bisschen schlauer macht, dann wird man feststellen, dass man da unter all diese Verordnungen gar nicht fällt. Hängt jetzt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab, ob dein kleines Gerät so Sachen wie Netzspannung involviert oder so. Denn sieht es unter Umständen doch wieder anders aus.
Aber so ein USB-Gerät oder sowas könnte da irgendwie drumherum kommen.
Solange du da die Warnhinweise ordentlich dazuschreibst, dass das für Bastler ist und dass es zum selberlöten ist, bist du da, denke ich, komplett raus. Selbst wenn du mit 220 irgendwas oder 230, also mit Spannung, echter Spannung was machst, immer als Selbstbauprojekt deklarieren und schon auf der Website keine Verantwortung für etwaige Schäden und Achtung, Hochspannung und so weiter raufschreiben. Auch die Müllverordnung ist, denke ich, bei Selbstbauprojekten, also typisch ist das, die Leute die fertige Platine anbieten und die Teileliste bei Reichelt. Und dann braucht man bei Reichelt nur ja, ich will, zu klicken und sich das dann zu Hause aufzulüten.
Wenn du es aber als fertige Kiste verkaufen willst, mit Preisschildrand und allem Drum und Dran, dann fällt so eine andere Baustelle, genau. Dann viel Glück beim Reichwerden.
Aber auch das ist nicht so dramatisch. Also das lizenziert, also alle Bauteile, die man heute so bekommt, sind sowieso ROHS, also haben diese Norm, dass da kein Blei drin ist und was nicht alles. Und man muss eben in seine Kalkulation mit einbeziehen, dass man so und so viel Geld schon mal abdrücken muss für die Rücknahme des Gerätes, also für die Entsorgung des Mülls am Ende. Das ist aber letztlich ein Kostenfaktor und man muss eben da ein bisschen Papierkram erfüllen. Das ist aber nicht unmachbar, sondern das muss man halt einmal machen. Da muss man sich mal zurechtklicken, wo man sich, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, auswendig, wo man sich hinwendet und dann Papiere ausfüllen, Geld bezahlen, fertig.
Solltest du aber einen Rechner bauen wollen, der irgendwas mit Fenstern zu tun hat und nicht funktioniert? Ich glaube, die Industrie- und Handelskammer kann dir da möglicherweise weiterhelfen. Und diesen lästigen Anfragen, welche Verordnungen denn jetzt hier bitte zu beachten sei, oder ob du da drunterfällst oder nicht, das würde ich da jetzt mal so üblich als den richtigen Ansprechpartner. Zumindest sollten die dir einen richtigen Tipp geben werden, wenn du ihnen aufwies.
Die Bestücker wissen das auch. Also wenn du eine Platine fertigen lässt und die bestücken lässt, der Bestücker, der weiß das.
Wenn ich die bestücken lasse, dann muss ja eigentlich derjenige, der die bestückt hat, das bezahlen, oder?
Nee, das sind Dienstleister. Denen sagst du, was sie tun sollen, und dann tun die das.
Aber die haben Erfahrungen damit.
Bleibt ja dein Ding sozusagen, trotz alledem. Und du verschäbelst es in irgendeiner Form, dann hat der Bestücker jetzt nichts mit zu tun. Pass auf deine Düsen, Tripp. Wir wünschen dir auf jeden Fall viel Glück beim Reichwerden. Sollte die erste Million quasi überschritten sein, kannst du ja dem Chaos Computer Club eine dezente Spende zukommen lassen. Die freuen sich. Tschüss. 0331 70 97 110 Sachen an denen ihr dengelt oder die ihr gedenkt zu dengeln. Darüber kann man hier heute reden im Blue Moon. Nach den Nachrichten geht es weiter mit Martin aus Weißensee. Der will was zu Grafikkarten erzählen und Thomas aus Sachsen ist auch gleich dran. Tschüss Eben gerade kam noch ein Anrufer, der noch anmerkte, das solltest du an elektrischen Geräten bauen oder elektronischen Geräten und die Kopf verkaufen wollen, dann musst du auf jeden Fall ein CE Zeichen drauf und eine EMV Nummer, also steckt da keinen Unsinn zusammen.
Hallo ihr Lieben, hier ist die Mieze von Nia. Wir planen einen Riesen-Zirkus in der Arena und dabei geht es nicht nur um Feuerschlucke und Stelzenlaufen, sondern vor allen Dingen geht es darum zu tanzen, zu rocken und sich verzaubern zu lassen.
Fritz präsentiert Mia live in Berlin mit Gästen aus ganz Europa. Mia auf Zirkustour.
Live bei PopdeRob.
Und das hört man. Fritz Info.
Mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Bei der Bewachung von Globalisierungskritikern soll die Polizei offenbar Hilfe von der Deutschen Bahn bekommen. Die Süddeutsche Zeitung berichtet, Zugbegleiter in Fernzügen seien angewiesen worden, potenzielle Demonstrantengruppen, die in Richtung Mecklenburg-Vorpommern unterwegs sind, an die Polizei zu melden. So könne möglichen Gefahren potenzial frühzeitig und konsequent entgegengewirkt werden, hieß es. In Potsdam haben etwa 1000 Menschen gegen den G8-Gipfel demonstriert. Sie zogen Richtung Schloss Sezilienhof. Dort hatten sich vorher die Außenminister der G8-Staaten getroffen, um den Gipfel in Heidikendamm vorzubereiten. Nach Polizeieingaben verlief die Demonstration überwiegend friedlich. Norwegen ist einer Studie zufolge das friedlichste Land der Welt. Schlusslicht ist der Irak. Der steht im Global Peace Index, der erstmals in London veröffentlicht wurde. Der Index listet mehr als 120 Staaten auf. Deutschland kommt in puncto Friedlichkeit auf Platz 12. Die USA liegen auf Rang 96, nur knapp vor dem Iran. Ebenfalls am Ende der Rangeliste befinden sich Israel und Russland. Eine Meldung vom Sport. Felix Maggert wird neuer Sportdirektor und Trainer beim Fußball-Bundesligisten Wolfsburg. Das haben die Niedersachsen nach einer Aufsichtsradsitzung bekannt gegeben. Nachts anfangs im Berliner Raum mit den Ostbrandenburg aufgelockert, nach Westen hingehren bewölkt und klar, überall bleibt es trocken. Die Tiefstemperatur und der Nacht liegen zwischen 7 und 12 in Berlin um 9 Grad. Morgen zunächst viel Sonne im Tagesverlauf, dann lockere Quellwolken. Es bleibt überall trocken, 20 bis 24 Grad. Wir haben keine Meldungen wünschen, gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Chaos Radio 124 im Blumen auf Fritz am heutigen 30. Mai 2007. Vom Chaos Computer Club sind Tim, Steini und Fiedel da. Wir reden heute über Schrauben 2.0, Schrägstrich die Chaos Radio Hobby-Thek. Schöne Überschrift von Nödel.
So, eh wird mein Titel aus.
Ja, dein Titel war Hands-On Hacking.
Ja, vielleicht ist deins besser, aber mir ist nichts eingefallen. Ich war abgelenkt, ich musste Küche bauen.
Ja, es geht, genau, da ist das Beispiel, es geht um Bauen. Vielleicht war da auch die Inspiration, Dinge bauen, zusammenschrauben und Erfindungen erfinden, die bis jetzt die Welt noch nicht gesehen hat und die die Welt aber brauchen sollte. Wir hatten gerade, im Chat tauchte ein, was? Ein Toaster auf, ein Roboter, der Toast selber beschmiert?
Ja, der möchte nicht anrufen, traut sie nicht. Ich kann auch nicht trotzdem am Ahnen.
Erzählst du vielleicht mal.
Genau, weil sie dann hier steht, Vichy schreibt, er hat einen Roboter gebaut, der Butterbrote schmiert, aber er traut sie nicht anzurufen, weil wir ihn bestimmt verarschen.
Also wenn sie arscheln, ruf bitte an. Interessante Frage ist, A, muss man das Brot vorher schneiden, macht er das selber, B, kann der auch Honig?
Ja, wir haben viele Fragen, ruf an.
Du hast gerade auch erzählt von einem Toaster, der eine Matrix auf den Toast drauf brennt? Ja, gibt es jetzt wohl, also so Toaster, die Logos toasten, gibt es wohl schon länger. Es gab vor sieben Jahren den Toaster, der das Fritz-Logo auf den Toast geknallt hat. Auch eine sehr naheliegende Idee und jetzt letztens lief einer über meinen Bildschirm, der macht wohl so dot-matrix-style beliebige Bilder in deinen Toast rein mit irgendeiner kleinen Auflösung, aber erkennbar. Kriegt man wahrscheinlich kalten Toast, aber dafür schön illustriert. Ob und wenn ihr an solchen Dingern dängelt und ob das auch mit Vollkorn-Toast geht, wenn man das sieht, dann wäre interessant das zu erfahren. 0331 77 97 110 oder aber im Chat. Der nächste am Telefon ist Martin aus, steht hier gar nicht, hallo Martin, wo kommst du her?
Aus Weißensee.
Aus Weißensee. Das ist Berlin. Was ist dein Begehr?
Und zwar, ich hab ne Grafikkarte, die vom Hersteller aus nicht auf der Internetseite ersichtlich ist. Ist sehr kurios. Ich war aber im Media Markt bei der Ton, also bei allen großen Fachhändlern, sprich auch bei den Klien. Und diese Grafikkarte, die ich habe, die kennt kein Mensch. Ich kenn nicht mal dieser Hersteller selber.
Ist das vielleicht ein CD-Rom-Laufwerk?
Nee, das ist eine ATI 128 Bravo XT.
Und was hast du damit gemacht?
Ja, die hatte ich mir gekauft, natürlich. Onboard hatte Grafik und das bringt beim Spiel nicht viel. Hatte sie mir gekauft, ist eine Maschine mit 256 MB mittlerweile, kurzerweise. Jetzt habe ich ein Problem. Hatte mir die neuen C und C-Teile gekauft, konnte genau eine halbe Stunde spielen, zack, war der Monitor aus kein Eingangssignal.
Willst du jetzt deine PC-Probleme schildern oder hast du selber was gebaut?
Naja, ich hatte extra bei dem jungen Mann eben gesagt, ich will eine Grafikkarte, weil mich jetzt interessieren wird. Bruder, ich kann keine Spiele mehr spielen.
Dann musst du dir Heißkleber kurfen und mal selber was bauen.
Achso, ich dachte ihr könnt mir helfen, weil ihr das denke ich mal...
Ne, Ferndiagnosen von Grafikkartenproblemen sind tatsächlich... Das ist wie immer im Auto, klappert links, was ist denn das? Martin, ich fürchte wir können dir da nicht wirklich weiterhelfen, wenn du da, wenn es der Hersteller nicht weiß und sonst keiner, vielleicht gibt es irgendeinen Internetforum, die dir da weiterhelfen könnte, dann muss man mal Google anwerfen.
Ja auch, tschüss! Also wir sind schon eine Beratungs-Sendung heute, aber nicht für eure PC-Probleme als solche. Ja genau.
Was steht denn auf ihrem Monitor, eine Blumenvase?
Ja, viele wollten eine Ode aussprechen.
Ich dachte, man müsste sowas bestimmt mal tun, an die wesentlichen Dinge, die sozusagen den Bastelalltag überhaupt erst ermöglichen. Da fallen mir halt spontan so...
Was braucht man denn genau?
Ja, also ich glaube, drei unverzichtbare Ingredienzen sind Heißkleber, Kabelbinder und bei mir persönlich abnehmendem Maße Kafferband. Ansonsten gibt es da bestimmt auch noch, ja, mehr.
Oh ja, also viel mehr. Und was ich auch total super finde, wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen größer denkt, Spanngurte. Spanngurte, ganz groß. Also wir haben wegen unserer zweiten Blinkenlight Installation wie viel haben wir gekauft?
200.
Nur? Nee, es waren mehr.
Wir brauchten 200, wir haben wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr gekauft.
Ja, wir haben einfach eine irre Anzahl an 3 Meter Spanngurten gekauft. Und ihr könnt euch überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie geil große Mengen an Spanngurten sind. Man kann sich mit Spanngurten einfach alles bauen. Nimmst du ein paar Paletten, mit Spanngurten kriegst du irgendwie alles zusammen. Kannst du Duschen draus bauen, kannst du Häuser draus bauen, kannst du alles draus bauen. Großartig. Ich schreib Spanngurte noch mit auf die Liste. Stani, hast du noch was?
Was?
So Dinge, die man so braucht. Heißkleber, Gaffer, Kabelwinder, Spanngurte.
Akkuschrauber, Spackschrauben, Lötkolben, Kolefonium. Werkzeug braucht man natürlich immer, aber so, ich sag mal, universelle Verbrauchsmaterialien.
Ich glaub, mit Kabelwindern kommt man schon ganz schön weit. Aber das ist ja im Wesentlichen alles immer so zum Festmachen, ne?
Ja, Befestigung, aber ich mein, im Grunde genommen...
Ja, aber damit hast du echt zu tun, also dauernd.
Ist Befestigung schon so ein universales Thema?
Aber ohne Heißkleber geht gar nichts, das ist wirklich ganz frei vorne.
Wer sich die Experten hier noch streiten fragt, da kommt mal Sven aus Lichenberg, der hat sehr viel in seiner Wohnung selber gebaut. Hallo Sven.
Mahlzeit, Abend, was auch immer.
Was braucht man? Doch, kann man prima Kabel schälen, eine Land mit festmachen.
Man kann auch die Schränke an die Wände knallen. Bei Steibetonwänden ist das notwendig.
Meine Elektriker machen das auch gern.
Echt, dann ballerst du einfach den Bolzen da direkt rein.
Ja, ich hab's auch schon geschafft, das Ding durchzuhauen. Da hat sich die Nachbarn gefreut.
Es ist aber niemals zu Schaden gekommen, hoffentlich.
Ich find das vielleicht lustig.
Meine Ausradsversicherung fand das nicht gut.
Ist klar, du kannst auch so einen mechanischen Tacker einlegen.
Der geht aber nicht in Steibeton.
Echt, wenn du mit dem Bolzen kommst, in Steibeton rein?
Ja sicher, das Ding setzt da an und so wumm damit kannst du auch quer, wenn du hier Gipskartonwände hast zum Beispiel, das Ding haust du durch, durch fünf Wände.
Da gibt's doch dieses kuriose Foto von einem, der sich aus Versehen so einen Nagel quer am Kiefer vorbei in den Kopf gerammt hat, ohne es gemerkt zu haben. Er meinte er hätte dann irgendwie so komische Zahn- und Kopfschmerzen und der Zahnarzt konnte ihm nicht weiterhelfen, dann haben sie ihn mal geröncht und dann haben sie diesen Bolzen da im Kopf stecken gefunden. Er hat tatsächlich aus Versehen an allem vorbei geschossen und es war kein Problem, aber er hat es halt auch nicht gemerkt, weil das Ding ist losgegangen, das hat eine derartige Wucht, das merkst du nicht.
Pass auf, Sven, du erzählst mir jetzt auch noch, dass du wahrscheinlich mit einem handelsüblichen Kanongrenatwerfer deinen Toast fabrizierst. Was baust du alles in deiner Wohnung?
Ich hab viel verändert. Ich hab zum Beispiel dadurch, dass die Küche sehr klein ist. Die hat gerade mal, ich glaube, lasst mich lügen, vier Quadratmeter. Wirklich viel Platz ist da nicht. Da muss ich natürlich Markereigenbaum in eine eigene Küche reinsetzen. Wenn man gerade dabei ist, kann man natürlich auch gleich einen kleinen TFT einbauen, einen kleinen Rechner oben im Schrank reinsetzen, das Ganze miteinander vernetzen. Man möchte natürlich auch Musik hören. Nicht nur Radio, man möchte auch seine Laute, seine gute Musik hören. Das gleiche im Wohnzimmer. Man möchte auch vernünftig Fernsehen gucken. Man möchte nicht aufstehen unbedingt. Jetzt genau den Film suchen. Dann greift man einfach auf die Festplatte zu, vom Hauptrechner und dann kann man gucken, was man will. Zum Beispiel. Also man vernetzt sich sozusagen, auf gut Deutsch.
Und das passiert per Kabel oder Wireless?
Nee, Kabel. Wireless-Lahn werde hier ein bisschen problematisch. Ich wohne im 11. Stock. Wenn ich dir sage, dass dieser Stock nachträglich aufgesetzt worden ist und hier so viel Funktiereisen drin steckt, da werde ich kein Signal kriegen. Übrigens, was ich noch sagen wollte, zu den Kollegen, der vor mir war. Die Grafikkarte kann keiner kennen oder selten jemand kennen. Das ist Marke Eigenbau. Das ist ein Bastel-Set gewesen. Man hat aus einer ATI Radeon 1500 Pro eine Bastel-Nicht-Selbst-Grafikkarte gemacht.
War ja doch nicht so falsch.
War nicht ganz falsch. Er hat es wahrscheinlich nicht selber gebastelt. Ich kannte das daher, weil ich das auch schon mal gemacht habe. Aber das nimmt ein böses Ende mit dem Motherboard. Nicht gut.
So an Grafikkarten rum zu basteln.
Gute Bausätze. Das macht ganz viel Spaß. Wenn man zum Beispiel eine alte Elza Vectoria 3D Prophet mal einen großen Lüfter drauf setzt, vorher noch den schönen kleinen Prozessor runterlötet und einen besseren rauflötet, was meinst du, was das für ein schönes Bild macht? Wird zwar scheiß heiß, kannst du einen Steak drauf brutzeln, aber dafür ist ja der neue Lüfter da.
Was machst du mit dem Bildschirm in der Küche, was mich interessieren würde?
Naja, ich muss ja das Ganze ein bisschen steuern. Wenn ich dann mal Langeweile habe oder am Wochenende da sitze und mein Frühstück zu mir nehme, dann kann ich da meinen Film gucken oder meine Serie, je nachdem worauf ich gerade Bock habe.
Das ist mehr so ein Fernseher.
Nein, multimedia mäßig kann man sagen. Man kann ja alles damit machen. Ich kann zum Beispiel, wenn ich gar keinen Bock habe, ach Mensch, Hausaufgaben, muss ich jetzt extra noch rübergehen und gucken, wo das alles ist. Kann ich da mal schnell ins Internet flüpfen.
Ich meine, du hast bei einer 4-Quadratmeter-Küche auch einen echt langen Weg zu deinem Schreibtisch.
Ich hab da 60-Quadratmeter-Wohnung. Also ich hab das mal gezählt. Die Schritte sind genau exakt um und nur 12 Schritte. Ja, das sind 12 Schritte zu viel.
Und wie wir alle wissen, länger als zwei Fahrzeuglängen laufen, ist Landstreicherei.
Du hast schon mal drüber nachgedacht, deine Küche soweit zu automatisieren, dass du vielleicht gar nicht mehr hingehen musst?
Ich hab so sehr schwer geschafft, mir unter meinem Schreibtisch einen Kühlschrank runterzubauen, weil ich Langeweile hatte.
Da hast du die Küche ja wieder ausgelagert. Ich dachte, ich träum ja immer so ein bisschen davon, so eine Nutri-Matik, so eine Maschine zu haben, die mir dann die ganzen Zutaten auch aus so automatisierten Abfüllsystemen, Spendern einfach alles zusammenmengt.
Nennst doch einfach Büchsenfrasen.
Das meine ich ja gerade aus frischen Sachen. Du hast halt irgendwie so einen Gewürzspender, so einen automatisierten und dann einen Teigkneter und dann kommt da irgendwie das Ei direkt aus dem Kühlschrank rausgefettet.
Und dann geht der Strom aus und dann weißt du nicht, wie man sich in den Mühen schläft.
Wenn der Strom ausgeht, stehen wir alle doof da.
Nö, da gibt es dann Kerzen und dann nimmt man sich ein Buch und liest mal ne Runde.
Jaja, das sagt mir der Typ, der sich irgendwie Internet in die Küche legt.
Da musst du zum Regal gehen, hast du das bedacht.
Hast du recht, dann ist es ja dunkel. Was mir aber noch auffällt, ihr habt jetzt vorhin jemanden, der sich angeblich nicht getraut hat wegen so einem Roboter.
Der Butterstollenroboter.
Ich hab hier zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr was kennt, einen Real Robot, sagt euch das was?
Mir nicht.
Es gab vor bestimmt zwei Jahren, ja genau, vor zwei Jahren gab es dann nicht mehr, sie haben es jetzt abgesetzt, gab es mal eine Zeitschrift, da konntest du dir per Hand einen Roboter zusammenbauen.
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich.
So geil ist das Teil, ich hab zwei Stück hier zu stehen.
Sind diese leicht bläulichen, ne?
Gibt's auch in rot.
Gibt's auch in rot, das ist gut für Mädchen.
Ja, nee, das ist, dann ist er aufgepinnt, hat da einen Spoiler vorne dran und hinten einen Heck-Spoiler. Und mit denen kannst du sogar Fußball spielen. Die spielen gegenseitig Fußball. Dann gibt's so einen digitalen Ball, der ist dann auch mit viel Technik ausgestattet, mit Infrarot und Piepsing, und dann hast du ein Tor, da ist ein Bewegungssensor drin, und dann können die spielen, die da Fußball halten. Ist richtig lustig, das Teil.
Ja, ich erinnere mich an die Geschichte, da gab es sozusagen zu jeder Ausgabe der Zeitschrift irgendwie noch einen neuen Sensor, oder?
Ja, aber wenn ich dir mal erzähle, was das Spaß, das kostet, hat, ich hab mir das mal durchgerechnet. Das sind 128 Zeitschriften.
Das war genau das Geschäftsmodell des Herstellers.
Richtig, aber ich sag mal so, es war wie Finanzkauf auf gut Deutsch. Ich hab immer genau bezahlt, war nicht irgendwie auf Raten, sondern es war immer meins, war ja praktisch. Genauso mit meinem Schreibtisch, den hab ich mir auch zusammengebastelt, aus vier Arbeitsplatten, zwei Stahlregalen, einen Stahlteeträger und einen Obermast.
Das klingt nach dem nicht Schreibtisch, sondern Schreibzimmer.
Klingt mehr nach einer Schreibfabrik, wenn ich weiß.
Ja, ich hab schon mal das Glück gehabt, dass mein Schreibtisch unter vier Monitoren und drei Rechnern zusammengebrochen ist.
Und seitdem gibt's das nicht mehr.
Also anstatt dir TFT-Monitore zu holen, holst du dir einen Stahl- und T-Träger rein.
TFT-Monitore haben einen kleinen Mankerl, die Farbe ist nicht so schön kräftig, was zum Beispiel Fotos angeht. Sie sind nicht so schön kristallklar. Und man kann nicht so schön mit 3D-Brillen gucken.
Das machst du die ganze Zeit?
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel Spiele spielt, wie Counter-Strike oder Battle Royale zum Beispiel, dann braucht man schon eine 3D-Brille. Macht schon mehr Spaß.
Okay, Sven, auch an dich die nächste Frage. Welches Projekt steht als nächstes auf deinem Notizzettel?
Der Fluor.
Der ist auch noch nicht online?
Der ist auch noch nicht online. Da möchte ich ein integriertes, in der Gipswand versenktes TFT-Modul versenken.
Warum?
Weil ich darüber dann alles steuere. Ich hab dann demnächst vor dann zum Beispiel automatisch runterfahrende Rollladen, weil ich ja nun genau die Sonnenseite habe, dann so Fensterrollen runterfahren.
Du hast so viele, glaube ich, so viele amerikanische Filme geguckt, wo man in sein Apartment kommt, einmal auf die Wand drückt und dann geht automatisch die Musik an und die Lampen gehen aus.
Ja, warum nicht? Ich hab zum Beispiel auch in meinem Badezimmer zwei Boxen und in meinem Wohnzimmer ein Fronz-System und die sind alle miteinander gekoppelt. Wenn ich ins Schlafzimmer die Musik ausmache, geht's im Wohnzimmer an und dann kann ich da mich halt hinsetzen und dann die gleiche Musik weiterhören.
Ich wünsche dir viel Glück und ganz kurz die Bitte, wenn du an deine Fenster guckst, lass da keine Rouladen runterkommen. Das ist unangenehm, besonders wenn die Sonne drauf scheint.
Alles klar, ich wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen Abend. Lasst euch nicht ärgern, bleibt weiterhin so lustig, cool und locker drauf, wie ihr seid.
Auf keinen, mach bitte keinen Blödsinn mit diesem Bolzenschussgericht. Das klingt sehr abenteuerlich.
Ich hab momentan keine Bolzen da, ich muss mir erst welche kaufen.
Freunde, die ihr bei Sven in der Nähe wohnt, ihr könnt jetzt losgehen und eure Altstoffe wegbringen.
Das bringt mich übrigens gerade noch hier auf den Punkt, was natürlich super populär ist, was viele Leute benutzen, hat aber bisher noch keiner erwähnt. Es gibt ja von Lego auch diese Roboter-Serie. Angefangen hat es mit diesen Mindstorms.
Das ist der Nachfolger von Lego Technik irgendwie, ne?
Ja, weiß nicht, wie man das...
Nachfolger nicht direkt.
Ja, Lego Technik ist halt so Lego, was auf Mechanik und so weiter ist, aber dann kamen halt die ersten Computer-Steuerungen, wo eben auch so Sensoren dabei waren. Also Lichtsensor, Abstandsensor, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, so vier, fünf, sechs verschiedene Sensoren und eben so ein programmierbares Schaltmodul. Vor einiger Zeit gab es dann ein Update. Jetzt heißt es, glaube ich, NXT. Und das ist auch ein offenes System, auch unter Linux supportet und hat eine eigene Programmiersprache. Ich hab's mir selber noch nicht angeschaut. Ich weiß nur, dass einige Leute damit am Experimentieren sind. Und die sind natürlich auch extrem flexibel, allein schon weil das eben Lego ist und jeder weiß, was man da für ihre Sachen bauen kann.
Aber dem muss ich was entgegenstellen. Fischertechnik ist einfach mal cool.
Ah, ein Fischertechnik-Freak.
Naja, die sind jetzt eigentlich noch auf dem Stand von Lego Robotik 1. Da gibt es eben auch so ein Robotmodul. Aber grundsätzlich ist Lego meiner Meinung nach echt wesentlich flexibler. Das ist halt so ein Prinzip Schüco in klein, also diese Alustreben. Was ist das Flexibler, Lego oder Fischertechnik? Das ist echt 3D. Lego ist im Wesentlichen 2, 5D, sag ich mal. Das heißt, du musst in Schichten aufbauen und du hast dann so Bauteile mit lauter Löchern drin, wo du dann Achsen durchstecken kannst. Aber das ist nicht echt 3D. Und Fischertechnik ist halt wirklich 3D. Das heißt, du hast da was, da kannst du vorne, hinten, links, rechts und oben und unten was ranbauen.
Besser für Kräne.
Ja, besser für Kräne, besser für Automation. Man ist ja auch eigentlich entwickelt, um eben so Fertigungsstraßen und Mechanismen auszuprobieren. Und daraus hat sich eigentlich ein Spielzeug entwickelt. Und das ist um Längen besser als Lego.
Es zählt ja heute aber nicht das Spielzeug, sondern es zählt die Projekte, die man so an Start bringt. Wir haben vorhin über Blinkenlides gesprochen. Und wir haben Roland aus München am Telefon. Hallo Roland.
Ich hab Blinkenlides irgendwie gehört vor uns, ganz kurz von euch. Und ich find das total cool, wie ihr da mit den Spannkunden rummacht. Und wartet gleich die Frage, die sich mir da stellte. Seid ihr auf dem Chaos Communication Camp?
Ich glaub wir veranstalten das.
Ja, ne klar, aber ihr als Attraktion seid ihr sozusagen.
Wir sind da glaube ich nur als Person, eine Attraktion, weiß ich gar nicht, ob wir da was dabei haben.
Na ja, sagen wir mal, Blinkenlides hat auch eine riesige Community nach sich gezogen. Kannst mal schauen unter blinkenarea.org zum Beispiel. Da sind ganz viele Projekte zusammengetragen. Es gibt zahlreiche Nachbauten in allen Formen, Farben, Größenordnungen und Ausführungen. Ich weiß, dass auch einige davon regelmäßig auf Kongressen sind und auch auf diesem Camp wieder. Also es gibt da sowieso so eine Community, die sich da schon sozusagen entwickelt hat.
Ne, da muss ich mal schauen, weil ich will jetzt da so ein oder ein paar Leute wollen in so ein Village noch bauen auf diesem Camp. Nennt sich da ein Privacy Village. Also das ist so FöBoot und AK-Forrest Datenspeicherung. Also alle Leute, die sich so für Datenschutz organisieren. Und da brauchen wir halt noch ein bisschen so Dekoration und so. Und der Werner Blinkenleitz natürlich als Gast natürlich ganz super.
Ja, gut, also Blinkenleitz ist schon, ist sozusagen...
Schrauben 0.5.
Ist ohnehin CCC und ist immer irgendwie drin, aber wir werden jetzt da keine neue Installation aufbauen.
Stehen zu wenig Häuser rum.
Stehen auch zu wenig Häuser rum, ist ja halt mehr so für draußen. Es gibt keinen Mangel an Projekten, die sich mit blinkendem Zeug beschäftigen.
Wir werden gewiss auch den Lichtwürfel von...
Genau, du hast auch was gebaut.
Der Lichtwürfel, den Fidel und ich und noch ein paar andere Leute auf dem letzten Kongress gezeigt haben, der wird da hoffentlich ein bisschen stabiler und schicker.
Baut habt ihr das auf dem Kongress?
Könnt ihr vielleicht kurz erklären, was dieser Lichtwürfel ist?
Das war im Prinzip resultierend aus der Idee Blinkenlights, mal einen zellulären Automaten zu bauen. Das sind 1000 winzig kleine Platinen. Ist genau so ein Bastelprojekt eigentlich, wie das, worüber wir hier gerade reden. Da haben wir zusammengesessen, Erdgeist, Fidel und ich, und überlegt, wie würde man es denn machen, wenn man jetzt jeden einzelnen Lichtpunkt, eine Leuchttiode mit einer eigenen Intelligenz versehen, Wölte und den einzelnen ansteuern, und das auch noch in einem Netzwerk zu betreiben, das man völlig frei konfigurieren und verändern kann. Dabei kam dann die Farbeinheit raus. Also eine Leuchttiode mit einem Mikrocontroller auf der gleichen Platine. Die haben wir halt designt und drei Wochen vor Weihnachten noch schnell bei einem Fertiger hier in Berlin machen lassen. Und dann festgestellt, dass wenn man 1000 solche Chips hat und da drei Kabel rein und drei Kabel rausgehen, dass man dann 6000 löst stellen kann. Das hat uns dann so ein bisschen in Zeitverzucht gebracht. Aber am Ende hatten wir was, was schon ziemlich cool geleuchtet hat.
Also es ist ein 10x10.
Es ist ein 9x9x9 Würfel und die anderen Teile, die sind zum Spielen und für andere Projekte. Also 728 oder so Leuchtpunkte. Und deswegen eine ungerade Zahl, damit das Ding ein Zentrum hat. Und die kann man in einer beliebigen Farbe, Rot, Grün, Blau oder irgendeiner Mischung daraus ansteuern. Und das auch so schnell, dass man da Videos drauf anzeigen kann. Also auch 3D-Videos zum Beispiel oder Projekte drin rotieren. Und das wollen wir eben dann nochmal auf dem Camp nochmal in ordentlich, wenn das dann bis dahin wieder fertig ist.
Diesmal ohne 5 laufender Meter Heißkleber.
Das sehen wir dann, wenn wir da sind.
Auf dem Acker.
Das siehst du dann, wenn denn du da bist. Das wird sicherlich nicht zu übersehen sein. Aber gut, dass du nochmal das Camp angesprochen hast. Und diese Villages, das habe ich nämlich vorhin nicht erwähnt. Wir strukturieren das Camp in Villages, Dörfer. Das heißt, Gruppen mit ähnlich gelagerten Interessen finden sich in diesen Villages zusammen, damit das alles eine geografische Struktur bekommt. Man kann also dann sozusagen, wenn man irgendwie etwas macht, was im Kontext von dem ist, was andere Leute schon machen, sich dann eben auch direkt dort andocken, vielleicht sein Zelt auch direkt da in der Nähe aufbauen und dann eben dort mitmischen. Es gibt eine große Zahl an Villages. Wenn ihr mal auf events.cde schaut und auf den Wiki-Homepage-Link klickt, dann gibt es in dem Wiki zahlreiche Villages bereits. Ich habe es mir jetzt nicht durchgezählt, aber es sind viele.
Mit wie vielen Leuten rechnet ihr?
Ja, ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn es 2000 wären. Wir hatten jetzt die ersten beiden Male ein bisschen weniger, aber das Potenzial ist da. Die holländischen Veranstaltungen waren immer schon ein bisschen besser besucht. Mal schauen, also das lässt sich auch mal sehr schwer vorhersagen.
Hängt auch ein bisschen vom Wetter ab, ne?
Na ja, es hängt ein bisschen vom Wetter ab. Es hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab, inwieweit die Leute verstehen, was da eigentlich vor sich gehen wird. Aber mittlerweile hat sich es ganz gut rumgesprochen. Und wenn ihr noch im Zweifel seid, nochmal schaut euch das Video an vom letzten Mal, dann wisst ihr ja, glaube ich...
Ja, das kann ich auch nochmal unterstreichen. Solche Camps und solche Aktionen, das lohnt sich echt.
Du warst auf dem letzten Camp?
Auf What The Heck war ich, ja.
Und dramatischer als in Holland kann das Wetter ja nur wirklich nicht werden.
Ja, die holländischen Veranstaltungen saufen immer ab und bei uns brennt immer die Sonne.
Was wir da an Village planen, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das interessiert.
Ja, wir reden ja heute über, woran schraubt ihr gerade?
Genau, das soll so ein Datenschutz Village sein, das nennen wir das Privacy Village. Ich weiß nicht, das ist momentan so ein bisschen in den Medien, so Online-Durchsuchungen und Vorratsdatenspeicherung und AirFit und Zeug, eben was da unser Innenminister alles so verträumt hat. Und da wollen wir ein bisschen Zelte aufbauen und Diskussionsforen schaffen und Vorträge machen. Das ist eigentlich so, dass die Village Idee, und da haben sie jetzt schon einige Vereine da quasi bereit gezeigt, da mitzumachen und da schauen wir mal, wer da noch mitmachen will. Und das ist hoffnungsvoll, dass das irgendwie cool wird.
Danke für den Anruf.
Alles klar.
Viel Spaß aus dem Camp. Schöne Abend in München. Unser Minister ist ja auch Schirmherr vom Linux-Trag, ne?
Ja, da sind sie glaube ich nicht besonders glücklich damit. Generell mögen sie es natürlich, wenn das Innenministerium unterstützt, aber Herr Schäuble steht natürlich gerade in der Community nicht gerade besonders hoch im Ranking. Vielleicht sollten wir mal auf was hinweisen, bevor wir es wieder vergessen. Wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, das Ganze ist auch derzeit ein wirklicher Trend. Gerade im Netz, Selbstbauprojekte sind neu entdeckt. Es gibt zum Beispiel von O'Reilly dieses wunderbare Magazin Make, das vor zwei Jahren oder so rausgekommen ist.
makezine.com ist glaube ich die Nachseite.
Genau, makezine.com, also markezine.com. Es gibt auch noch einen Ableger, der sich mit weniger elektronischen Sachen, sondern mit handwerklichen Sachen, das ist dann Craft und entsprechend craftzine.com. Die haben ein extrem lebendiges Blog, also allein dieses Blog mal zu verfolgen. Und der Makezine, das ist einfach absurd. Also ich glaube, die posten pro Tag acht coole Projekte, so ein Mittel ungefähr, vielleicht auch mittlerweile schon mehr geworden. Ich weiß nicht, das ist fast nicht zu konsumieren, aber einfach geile Sachen. Also alles was Leute so bauen, Hacks aller Art, kleine Sachen, große Sachen, das wird dort dokumentiert. Ähnlich interessant und auch ähnliche Sachen gibt es bei hackaday.com. Also hackaday sozusagen, jeden Tag ein Hack. Ich weiß nicht, ist wirklich jeden Tag einer. Ist schon auch mal mehr oder mal weniger, je nachdem, wie das in diesem Fall vloggt.
Aber sehr cool, also da gibt es wirklich ganz, ganz viele, ganz großartige Ideen. Ich würde sie jetzt empfehlen.
Und was auch noch zu empfehlen ist, das hast du dir aber glaube ich besser angeschaut, das instructables.com.
Instructables, ja das ist im Wesentlichen eine Website für Bauanleitungen. Also so einfach Beschreibungen, wie was gemacht wird. Also der Trend geht jetzt wirklich in die Richtung, Sachen selber zu machen. Und dann gibt es auch Sites, wo man die dann anbieten kann, zum selber eben zum Verkaufen in kleinen Stückzahlen. Oder immer hatte ich auch irgendwo notiert. Da haben wir sie, genau. etsy.com, www.etsy.com. Das ist so die Mutter aller Websites für selbst gebaute Dinge, um die dort anzubieten, also Einzelstücke und die Karte und so weiter. Dann gibt es hier einen Web 2.0-Ableger in Deutschland. Davanda.de, das klingt auch schon wieder so richtig.
Was für Sachen werden da angeboten?
Ach, das ist wirklich alles. Also das ist jetzt so vom gehickelten Topflappen bis zur selbstgebauten weißer Geier.
Mondrakete.
Ja, Mondrakete jetzt vielleicht nicht gerade. Aber so tatsächlich Leute, die Unikate bauen und anbieten. Das Instructables eben ist eher so eine Community für Anleitung, für Do-It-Yourself-Anleitung. Also auch eine gute Quelle, wenn einmal langweilig ist, und man sich überlegt, was könnte man denn mal bauen? Wie kann man mal die Zeit totschlagen, außer vor dem Fernseher zu sitzen? Da gibt es ohne Ende Anregungen. Und es ist also absolut empfehlenswert, sich da mal so ein bisschen durchzuklicken.
Es gab zwei ganz interessante Stichworte, die hier vielen, die wir in der nächsten Stunde noch klären werden. Das eine ist We-Mode, also die Modifikation der Nintendo Wii und selbstgebaute Drohnen und solche Sachen. Das klären wir gleich vorher speziell für Tim und alle anderen, die auch quasi an Radio Interna interessiert sind. Jetzt kommt der sogenannte Opener, also die Musik, die jemand zur vollen Stunde sagt, hallo, die Sendung heißt so. Und jetzt ist es männlich. Das ist eine Frau, weiblich wird's, ne?
Ja.
Verrückt.
Blumenau Fritz, Chaos Radio Teil 124 mit Tim Steini und Fiedl vom Chaos Computer Club. Wir reden heute über... Deine schöne Formulierung ist so toll, ich möchte die ungern wegnehmen. Also ich sag Schrauben 2.0, die Chaos Radio Hobby-Thek.
Ist super, wie du magst. Also passt auch.
Wie habts vielleicht mitbekommen, so in den letzten Minuten reingeschaltet hab, Dinge, die man selber bauen kann, wo der normale Mensch auf der Straße sich einen Kopf fasst und sagt, wieso braucht man das, warum machst du das, kannst du nicht Fernsehen gucken, wie jeder andere. Über solche Dinge reden wir heute. Wir haben über Blinkenlights schon gesprochen, das war die Installation, die ihr 2001 auf dem Alexanderplatz im Haus des Lehrers hattet. Wir hatten schon eine ganze Menge Geschichten und falls ihr auch solche Sachen habt, an irgendwas baut oder an irgendwas verzweifelt seid, dann ruft uns an oder klickt ins Netz fritz.de oder ccc.de chaosradio.ccc.de Da findet ihr den Kontakt zu uns, da könnt ihr gerne entweder mitchatten oder uns eine Mail schicken oder aber ihr ruft wie gesagt an und dann 0331 70 97 110. Bevor wir über We-Mode reden, das finde ich extrem spannend, reden wir erstmal mit Thomas aus, ja woher eigentlich, namen Thomas, Morgen Thomas. Ja hallo, von wo rufst du an?
Brandebusdorf, Sachsen.
Alles klar. Woran schraubst du am liebsten?
Einen möglichen. Ich bin Mechatroniker und gelernter Stahlbauer. Demnste eine sehr flexible, braune Schraube drehen kann.
Du bist gelernter was?
Mechatroniker und Stahlbauer.
Stahlbau, alles klar. Mechatronik heißt im Prinzip, du baust robotische Systeme.
Weniger, ich bin mehr im Fahrzeugbereich.
Ich glaub früher hieß sowas Elektromechaniker. Und was baust du da so?
Wir hatten schon mal einen dran, eine Glasfaser, der seine Fernbedienung durch die Wände schickt.
Genau, der Mensch, der auf seiner Terrasse dringend seine Stereoanlage fernbedienen möchte, oder die Fernbedienung zu kurz war, hat er sich ein Glasfaserkabel gelegt, um das zu bauen. Das passt nicht ganz. Und dann kam hier die Anregung, mach doch einfach einen Infrarot-Sensor und Infrarot-Empfänger, und dann dürfte das funktionieren.
Ja, ich krieg euch über die Astral-Digitalradio an. Und ich hab leider das jetzt von meiner Wohnstube runter über, also nicht über Chinsch, die kriegste ja nicht 30 Meter lang durch die Wand, sondern hab da die Chinschklinken aufgelöst durch den Telefonkabel und hab unten in der Garage jetzt noch einen Versteiger stehen, wo ich einen Ausgang für die Lautsprecher und Umschaltbox hab, für die Lautsprecher, und das dann hinleiten kann, wo ich spiele. Also ich hab überall Lautsprecher in meinem Haus, hier unten, im Garten, in der Garage, im Flur, und da schalt ich das hin, wo ich spiele. Und in jedem Lautsprecher ist da noch mal ein Body dran, also eigentlich ein regelbares Widerstand, wo ich das dann auf den Lauten laser drehen kann.
Das heißt, du machst quasi diese ganze Geschichte, die einige Leute versuchen, wireless, also drahtlos zu machen, und du machst das quasi in der Hemdsärmling-Variante mit Telefonkabel und Stecker unten dran. Alles klar.
Und das zweite ist so, gerade jetzt darauf bezogen, Force War, war Fußball werden. Und da hat ich mir für meine Laubetriebe ein Digitale-Receiver geholt. Kriegt man mittlerweile im Baumarkt hergeschmissen, kann man sagen, für 50 Euro mit Schüssel. Und dann hatte ich schon noch ein bisschen Fernseher geholt, so aus einem Aldi. Und dann wurde das Problem, dass man eigentlich schon an den Digitale-Receiver, aufgrund der Signalqualität, kein TV-Out hat, also das ATEM-Kabel, das Coax, gibt es nicht mehr. Und an dem Fernseher war nur TV-In, also das Coax-In und Skort-In. Und größter war jetzt die ähnliche Verbindungsmöglichkeit zwischen dem Receiver und dem Fernsehgerätbestand auf Skort-Base aus Skort-Kabel.
Das wird jetzt ein kleines bisschen sehr technisch. Also mit den ganzen Kabeln. Die Intention, das zu bauen. Du wolltest das alles in deinem Garten gucken, es hat nicht funktioniert. Soweit kann ich dir folgen.
Ich hab den Regie vom Garten, aber er lautet, und ich wollte draußen sein. Und da kriegst du keinen, also mit zwei Metern kommst du da nicht weit.
Da war er weg. Jetzt ist er irgendwie aus der Leitung gefallen. Thomas, irgendwie bist du jetzt gerade weg. Also ich glaube, das Ende der Geschichte, es geht dann irgendwie so weit, wie er seinen Fernseher aus der Laube mit dem Receiver verbindet. Machst du den Eindruck, da gibt es natürlich viele Möglichkeiten.
Wobei ich muss ja sagen, ich finde das ja immer so ein bisschen unspannend, wenn es eigentlich nur darum geht, Fernsehen und Audio zu übertragen, weil das ist einfach mal nicht interaktiv.
Ist richtig, aber auf der anderen Seite ist das der erste Schritt zum Weitergängeln. Da erstmal sagen, es geht und dann kann man weitermachen.
Ja, ist eine Baste.
Da glaube ich auch, dass das Musik kam ja glaube ich auch schon so ein bisschen durch. Das ist glaube ich einer der wesentlichen Anreize für Leute überhaupt da, mal sich mit dem Thema eigene Schrauben bauen, Stecker kaufen, einzeln, Lötkolben anwerfen, in welcher Form auch immer. Scheint mir Musik glaube ich ein ganz großer Anreiz, ein ganz großes Anreizthema zu sein. Im Auto, denn eben wieder auch die meisten Auto-Applikationen haben im Grunde genommen Premiere und zuallererst was mit Audio zu tun und dann in zweiter Reihe erst mit ja hier Display, Film gucken, Navigation, Pipapo.
Aber ich will mehr Sensoren sehen.
Das ist dein Lieblingsthema Wiimax, äh nicht Wiimax, sondern Wiimote.
Wiimax ist ganz was anderes.
Nächste Sendung, übernächste.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mein Lieblingsthema ist, aber das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Gerät, was gerade so ein bisschen populärer wird. Also wovon ich rede, ist die Wiimote, die Wi, die Nintendo Wi, also die neue Generation Spielkonsole von Nintendo, dieses kleine weiße Teil, sehr putzig und würde mir auch immer gehört haben, dass man da einfach jetzt mit so einem Teil in der Hand beliebige Bewegungen machen kann. Das Gerät ist in der Lage, die Geste als solche und auch wo man hin zeigt, ganz genau zu erkennen. Und das Schöne ist, dass diese Wiimote wird auch separat einzeln verkauft, kostet glaube ich 39 Euro und ist eigentlich ein kleines Wunderwerk der Technik. Da ist nämlich so alles drin, was man braucht für Gestenerkennung im Raum. Da ist ein Beschleunigungs-Sensor drin, also ein kleiner Chip, der in der Lage ist, eine Bewegung in eine bestimmte Richtung zu erkennen und auch zu sagen, wie schnell diese Bewegung ist. Und das eben für X, Y und Z. Das heißt, egal wie man den bewegt, die Wiimote weiß immer ganz genau, wo sie gerade hin und wie schnell bewegt wird. Dazu ist noch vorne eine kleine Kamera, die bei der Wii so verwendet wird, dass man eine Infrarotquelle hat. Das ist einfach so eine LED-Leiste, die leuchtet halt einfach infrarot aus. Das kann man ja auf so einem CCD, also so einem Kamerasensor, sehr gut erkennen, sodass man eben auch so einen Referenzpunkt im Raum dazu hat.
Damit die sich orientieren kann.
Genau, und dazu gibt es noch ein paar Tasten, ein paar ganz gut angelegte, die kann man schön benutzen, so oben und unten. Und das Ganze, und das macht die Sache eigentlich erst so interessant, funktioniert dann mit Bluetooth. Das heißt, die Wii ist mit ihrer Wii Remote über Bluetooth verbunden. Es gibt jetzt schon zahlreiche Treiber für Windows, für Mac, für Linux, wie man eben diese Wii Remote dann eben auch von dem normalen Computer aus auslesen kann. Und das macht das natürlich zu so einer universellen Steuerung. Ich habe schon ein paar echt coole Sachen gesehen, zum Beispiel diese Loop-Maschine von so einem Franzosen. Da müsst ihr mal gucken, da gibt es auf YouTube ein geiles Video zu, wo er das demonstriert. Er hat halt so ein Programm geschrieben, was einfach Loops bereithält. Ich glaube, das läuft auf dem Mac. Und über die Tasten der Wii-Mode kann er sich immer einen Loop raussuchen, kann also durchzyklen. Er zeigt das nur, wie er es bedient, nicht ganz genau, wie es funktioniert. Und wenn er sich so einen Loop ausgesucht hat, so ein Musikschlaufen-Rhythmus, wir wissen schon, Techno und so, dann kann er eben mit der Bewegung selber steuern, wie dieser Loop jetzt sich wiederholt, wie laut und leise der ist und so weiter. Das sieht super aus und klingt auch geil.
Musikinteraktion durch kreatives Fuchteln sozusagen.
Damit kann man einfach schöne Sachen bauen, wenn es um Fuchtel und Steuern geht.
Ich sehe da quasi neuartige Varianten der Diskothek. Wenn jeder Besucher so ein Ding in die Hand kriegt und dann werden die abwechselnd scharf geschaltet und dann kann man da quasi zu seiner eigenen Musik tanzen.
Genau, man kann zum Beispiel... Man braucht sich das Ding wahrscheinlich nur in den Gürtel zu klemmen. Und daran kann man schon erkennen, wer mit wem tanzt.
Nicht schlecht.
Und wie schnell.
Genau. Und vor allem was.
Aber noch cooler ist es eigentlich, wenn man so andere Sachen damit steuert. Und dazu braucht man natürlich auch erst mal was Cooles zum Steuern. Und das ist ja schon erwähnt, da müssen wir ja unbedingt Stein hier nochmal zu befragen, weil er ist ja unser Spezialexpert in dem Bereich. Der aktuelle Fall sind so Drohnen.
Richtig.
Also selbst fliegende Geräte zur Vollüberwachung.
Genau, und dafür braucht man solche Sensoren zu Hauf. Weil da reicht einfach ein Exhilarometer oder sogar drei, die rechtwinklig aufeinander stehen gar nicht aus.
Das sind diese Beschleunigungsmesser.
Das sind Beschleunigungsmesser, weil das Problem, das wir hier haben, ist ja, dass wir die Drohne in der Luft halten müssen erst mal.
Also beschreib erstmal, was das ist, eine Drohne. Ich glaube, das kann dir sicher nicht jeder was runter vorstellen.
Also ich sehe jetzt aus den Nachrichten, diese Militärdrohnen, diese Riesendinger, die aussehen wie Cross-Missiles. Man kann sowas wahrscheinlich auch einfacher auf so einem handelsüblichen Modellbauflugsatz bauen, oder?
Nee, nicht mal Modellbauflugsatz. Die Drohnen, die man heute so zum Fliegen nehmen würde, also vom Design her, das sind Geräte, die haben vier Propeller. Die sind alle wie ein Hubschrauberpropeller nach oben, aber das müssen nicht komplizierte Verstellrotoren sein. Jeder Propeller ist am Ende eines Kreuzes angebracht. Wir haben also ein Kreuz, vier Propeller, direkt die Motoren dran. Wenn ich die Motoren alle schneller mache, zwei Propeller drehen links rum, zwei drehen rechts rum, wenn ich alle Propeller Gas gebe, fliegt das Ding nach oben. Wenn ich auf einer Seite einen Propeller schneller mache, steigt diese Seite und die andere sinkt.
Das heißt, du lenkst sie dann?
Damit lenkt man und wenn man zwei Rotoren die gleiche Richtung drehen, schneller macht, dann dreht es sich auch. Da muss man die anderen beiden kurz ein bisschen langsamer machen, sonst steigt er eben gleichzeitig.
Da haben wir übrigens auch gleich Jörg am Telefon. Ich glaube, er will es genau zu der Geschichte erzählen.
Jetzt kurz zur Idee dahinter. Wie baut man sowas selber? Was wir hier brauchen, ist ein sogenanntes inertial measurement system. Das heißt, eine Sensorik, die uns jetzt zu jeder Zeit genau sagt, in welcher Lage im Raum sich das Ding befindet. Und das ist echt wahnsinnig kompliziert, weil wir haben überhaupt nichts, wozu relativ wir das sehen könnten. Das heißt, wir haben keinen Anhaltspunkt. Also der Mensch, der guckt dann so auf den Horizont. Und jeder kann sich vorstellen, wenn er in einem Flieger sitzt und es geht drunter und drüber, dann ist auch Schluss mit dem Horizont. Das heißt, irgendwie brauchen wir Anhaltspunkte, nach denen wir messen können, wo es eigentlich oben und unten ist.
Was die Wii mit ihrer Infrarotleiste hat. Der Mensch macht das mit dem Innen.
Ja, aber das Ding fliegt ja nicht.
Aber so als Anhaltspunkt für die Bewegung?
Genau, aber genau diesen Fixpunkt gibt es gar nicht.
Den gibt es nicht und deswegen braucht man eine Menge Sensoren. Das heißt, ich muss nicht nur feststellen, ob ich in irgendeiner Richtung beschleunigt wurde, sondern ich muss oben rein feststellen, ob ich in irgendeiner Richtung rotiert wurde. Weil das ja durchaus auch noch Aspekte hat. Wenn nämlich jetzt Wind bläst, dann wäre ich wohl durchaus in einer Richtung beschleunigt, aber nicht unbedingt rotiert. Daran kann ich nämlich erkennen, ich habe Wind drift und muss jetzt gegenlenken. Das macht man dann über einen Prozessor. Der rechnet dann aus, vergleicht die verschiedenen Sensoren und rechnet eben aus, was wohl jetzt am wahrscheinlichsten ist. Dann braucht man noch einen Luftdrucksensor.
Also bisher waren es nur Accelerometer.
Bis jetzt haben wir drei Accelerometer und drei Rotationssensoren, also Gyroskope. Das sind so Piezo oder ähnliche Messgeräte, die jetzt eine Rotationsbeschleunigung messen. Dazu brauchen wir jetzt noch einen Luftdrucksensor, der uns eben etwas über die Höhe aussagen kann. Wir wollen ja auch die Höhe stabil halten. Dann ist es sehr sinnvoll, um noch ein bisschen ein Absolutwert von außen zu bekommen, das Erdmagnetfeld zu messen, auch in drei Achsen. Dann kann ich noch mal die Genauigkeit erhöhen. Und um den ganzen dann...
Ein Klassikkompass dann.
Ein Kompass, aber nicht nur einen, der eben in einer Richtung misst, wo Norden ist, sondern der eben das Erdmagnetfeld in drei Komponenten misst, damit ich wieder ziemlich genau in jeder Richtung sagen kann, hat sich denn was verändert. Weil das ist tatsächlich das einzige, was ich rauskriege, ob sich denn was verändert hat. Und wenn sich was verändert hat, muss ich überlegen, was sagt mir denn das? Und das ist tatsächlich auch das eigentliche Problem. Damit die ganzen Sensoren besser arbeiten können, brauche ich auch so Faktoren wie Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit. So, dann sind wir glaube ich schon bei 14 Sensoren oder sowas.
Und bei einer Größe von 6 Quadratmetern und 20.000 EUR?
Nein, eben genau nicht. Also es gibt jetzt verschiedene Selbstbauprojekte zum Thema. Da kann man mal unter www.opensource-quadrocopter.de gucken. Oder auch www.microcopter.de. Das sind Selbstbauprojekte, das sind kleine Platinen mit Atmel Mikrocontrollern drauf und den Sensoren. Die kann man sich im Robotik-Teile-Laden gibt es mittlerweile bestellen. Die lötet man auf. Das wird so in einer Größenordnung, wenn man dann noch ein GPS dazu packt, damit man auch ungefähr weiß, wo man ist, liegt das jetzt so zwischen 500 und 1000 Euro. Und die Platine, die ist so 10 x 10 cm groß. Das ist so die Größenordnung, um die das ist. Das ist alles noch von Hand lötbar. Das heißt, da ist jetzt noch kein Ball-Grid-Array, also lauter kleine Pünktchen unten drauf, sondern alles noch so Zeug, das man noch mit Übung von Hand löten kann. Dann muss man eben eine Motorsteuerung haben, mit der man die einzelnen Motoren in der Geschwindigkeit verstellt. Da gibt es eben ein anderes Projekt, da hat man sich bedient an solchen Motorstellern. Die kann man auch noch selber löten. Das ist ein komplettes Selbstbauprojekt, mit dem man eine Drohne, also einen selbst fliegenden Roboter bauen kann, wo man unten eine Kamera anschließt und Luftbilder machen kann.
Vorher ist es ja eigentlich nur ein Flugobjekt, oder?
Genau.
Zur Drohne wird es tatsächlich nur, wenn man da irgendeine bildgebende oder wie auch immer Nutzlast appliziert.
Zur Drohne wird es eigentlich dadurch, dass es entbehrlich wird. Also eine Drohne unterscheidet sich von einem Modellflugzeug dadurch, dass man davon viele haben kann und nicht so schlimm ist, wenn eine weg ist.
Warum man sowas macht, das fragen wir jetzt mal Jorg aus Berlin. Name Jorg. Bist du, wenn ich das hier richtig blicke, im selben Thema?
Genau, ja. Also der Kollege da, der hat es schon sehr gut eingeleitet. Der hat ja auch schon sehr guten Einblick daran gegeben, wie sowas prinzipiell funktioniert. Und was ich jetzt mache, ich bastel nicht an einem Quattrocopter, sondern ich bau einen richtigen Hubschrauber auf. Also der hat ungefähr einen Rotadurchmesser von 2, 50 m und ein Abfluggewicht von jetzt maximal 25 kg.
Das ist schon mal seriös.
Ja, die 25 kg liegen im Moment an den gesetzlichen Beschränkungen. Also im Prinzip da ist die Grenze zum Modellflug, also beziehungsweise zwischen Modellflug und zulassungspflichtigen Flugobjekten sozusagen.
Also wenn es schwerer wird, müsstest du dafür irgendwie einen Schein haben oder sowas?
Nee, dann geht es weniger um den Schein, dann geht es vielmehr darum, dass das Flugobjekt selbst auch geprüft und zugelassen werden muss. Also man braucht dann im Prinzip eine lufthart Zulassung.
Dann wird es kompliziert mit anderen Worten.
Genau, weil da wird sowieso schon kompliziert, weil momentan nicht mal die Behörden so richtig wissen, nach welchen Kriterien ein Hubschrauber in der Größe geprüft werden muss.
Genau, aber lass uns nicht über die drögen Schlipse reden, lass uns über dein Bastelprojekt reden.
Ja, also das Projekt ist dem Bastelstadium ehrlich gesagt schon ein wenig entwachsen.
Ja, das klingt eigentlich so, stimmt.
Aber es ist letztendlich daraus entstanden. Und ja, wir bauen das also jetzt mit mehreren Leuten, also ich und zwei Kollegen noch, bauen das jetzt ein bisschen professioneller auf, um dann im Prinzip das auch sinnvoll anwenden zu können.
Wofür?
Wofür? Ja, natürlich für Luftaufnahmen. Also hauptsächlich wird so ein Hubschrauber immer eine Kamera mit sich rumschleppen. Und der ist nun deswegen auch etwas größer ausgefallen, weil er eben auch vernünftige Kameras tragen soll, also welche, die jetzt HD oder Broadcasting Qualität haben, sodass man im Prinzip dann auch gleich sehen kann, in welche Richtung das abzielt, also dass man es auch wirklich für Nachrichtenübertragungen, für Events, für TV, für Filmtakes und so weiter einsetzen kann.
Das heißt, du willst damit keinen quasi Wolfgang Schäuble Angst machen den Schindluder treiben, sondern du willst damit professionell arbeiten.
Nein, ehrlich gesagt, das ist das Letzte, was ich möchte, Herrn Schäuble damit Angst einzujagen, weil dann, glaube ich, geht das ganz schnell, dass man da super viele Steine in den Weg gelegt bekommt. Also wenn man sowas hat und baut, dann sollte man sich da schon strikt an die Regeln halten.
Arbeitest du in irgendeiner Form in diesem Film-Nachrichten-Business?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich bin noch an der TU im Moment und da haben wir dieses Projekt auch aufgezogen. Und das ist entstanden, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr davon schon mal gehört habt, es gibt in der TU den fliegenden Roboter Marwin. Und aus diesem Marwin ist das jetzt quasi eine Weiterentwicklung. Also Marwin ist ursprünglich 1997 gestartet worden und ist dann zum Jahr 2000 mit dem Ziel, in den USA in diesem Robotics Competition teilzunehmen, entwickelt worden, hat den im Jahr 2000 auch gewonnen. Und daraufhin ist das Projekt mal eingeschlafen und dann gab es EU-Projekte, wo dann untersucht wurde, wie denn viele Luftfahrzeuge, ob es jetzt UAVs, also unbemannte autonome Vehikel, also aerial autonome Vehikel sind oder ob es jetzt herangestellte Sachen sind, war dabei unerheblich. Da wurde untersucht, wie die alle zusammenarbeiten können und da wurden dann Leitstandstrukturen entwickelt und solche Sachen, Kommunikationsstrukturen und Hierarchien und sowas. Und da wurde im Prinzip nochmal eine zweite Version von Marwin aufgelegt. Da wurde er ein bisschen, na wie soll ich sagen, zuverlässiger aufgebaut und ein bisschen professioneller. Weil wir bei der ersten Version schon arge Probleme auch mit Auffällen hatten und so weiter, weil das alles mehr oder minder nur zusammengestöpselt und so zusammengefrimmelt war. Und jetzt die dritte Version, die soll im Prinzip ernsthaft anzuwenden sein.
Aber ihr verwende da schon auch Verbrennungsmotoren und sowas, ne? Also bei 25 Kilo klingt alles gegen das, ne?
Kannst du mal ein bisschen was zum Innenleben sagen, was da so alles drin steht?
Also der Hubfrau war selbst, ja das nehmen wir mal an, das interessiert euch hauptsächlich von der elektronischen Seite her.
Ach du, was auch immer interessant ist.
Wir schreiben fleißig mit und gehen morgen in den Baumarkt ein. Also den Motor habt ihr sicherlich nicht selber auf der Drehbank geschraubt, da gehen wir jetzt mal nicht von aus.
Den Motor gibt es einen sehr einschlägig bekannten Modellmotorhersteller. Der baut ernst zu nehmen, eine großvolumige Benzinmotoren, kann man schon sagen, also für den Modellbereich. Das ist 3W heißen die. Und die verdienen auch einen großen Teil ihres Geldes einfach mit Drohnen, indem die eben diese Motoren auch an Drohnenhersteller verkaufen. Und da haben wir uns auch einen Boxer-Motor zugelegt. Der wird dann um die 11 PS abliefern können. Und damit kann man schon einige Sprünge machen.
Und wie haltet ihr das jetzt oben? Macht ihr noch was mehr außer das, was ich gerade erzählt habe?
Im Prinzip machen wir jetzt, also die Sensoren, die du beschrieben hast, sind prinzipiell die gleichen. Wir verwenden nun zum Abgleich, letztendlich zum langfristigen Abgleich und auch um unsere Position möglichst exakt halten zu können, auch schon ziemlich teures GPS. Wir haben bisher immer ein Novatel GPS, RTK2, genommen. Und werden jetzt mal von Hemispheric Crest and Vector aus probieren. Das ist ein bisschen günstiger und hat den Vorteil, man kann zwei GPS-Antennen dranhängen und bekommt auch noch ein Accelerometer und ein Gyroskop mit drin. Das gibt uns dann im Prinzip gleich eine relativ zuverlässige Orientierung. Wie genau wird das dann mit zwei Antennen? Man hat die Wahl, die 0, 5 Meter oder 2 Meter auseinanderzupacken. Bei 0, 5 Meter kriegt man eine Viertelgrad Auflösung. Und bei 2 Metern glaube ich einen Zehntel Grad.
Aber habt ihr 2 Meter Länge?
Ja, 2 Meter ist kein Problem, der Heckausweger ist 1, 40 Meter lang. Und wenn man dann noch eins auf die Nase packt, dann hat man die 2 Meter auch zusammen.
Und nochmal, dann ist die Genauigkeit wie?
Zehntel Grad, 0, 1 Grad.
Zehntel Grad? Okay, das übersetzt sich in unseren Breiten in ungefähr was für eine Raumauflösung? Reden wir jetzt von Metern, Zentimetern?
Nee, dabei geht es jetzt rein um die Magnetorientierung, wenn man so will. Also das, was der Kompass tut, können wir im Prinzip damit entweder, ja, redundant ersetzen oder wir können den Kompass ganz weglassen, obwohl der Kompass immer noch eine gute Hilfe ist, weil er einem ja einen absoluten Vektor im Raum gibt.
Das heißt, ihr benutzt das GPS im Wesentlichen als wie dreh ich mich gerade?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Dieser Crashing Vector, der kann eben auch die Orientierung in der parallel zur Erde quasi mit rausgeben. Aber primär ist das GPS natürlich dazu da, um uns die Position zu geben.
Genau, und das meinte ich, wie genau dieses GPS dann ist.
Achso, das wäre im Bereich 20 cm.
Das kann man noch deutlich verbessern, aber das wisst ihr bestimmt, ne? Wenn man da ein Differential-Signal und die Phasenverschiebung noch auswertet.
Also das ist schon ein Differential-GPS. Das ist jetzt nicht ganz so teuer wie das Novatel. Also mit dem Novatel-Differential kommt man auf zwei Zentimeter. Nur der Punkt ist, die zwei Zentimeter braucht man gar nicht. Weil wenn der Hubschrauber erstmal eine Weile irgendwo in der Luft ist, dann sieht man gar nicht, ob der sich zehn Zentimeter bewegt oder ob er sich zwanzig Zentimeter bewegt. Das ist völlig unerheblich.
Du meinst bei einer Kamera jetzt? Wie bitte? Für die Kamera ist es unerheblich.
Ja, auch für die Positionierung. Also wenn man den Hubschrauber jetzt wirklich definiert irgendwo positionieren möchte und jetzt sagen wir, wir haben Verstörung durch Wind etc. Dann will man natürlich sicher gehen, dass der Hubschrauber dann nicht in den Pfannenmast oder in das Objekt, was er sich anschauen soll. Also man kann ja so einen Hubschrauber auch super einsetzen um zum Beispiel Windkraftanlagen, Strom, Installation etc. pp. wo man sonst nicht so ohne weiteres rankommt, um die dem zu inspizieren. Genau, Schornsteine, große Anlagen, Hochöfen.
Aber so wenn ihr so Wasserbomben abwerfen wollt, dann wäre ja sicherlich zwei Zentimeter Auflösung schon ganz hilfreich.
Ja, dann bräuchten wir aber auch eine Art Feuerleitsystem, was uns im Prinzip aufgrund von Windstärke etc. sagt, wo die Wasserbombe denn noch wirklich runterkommt.
Okay, damit sind wir wieder bei dem Bolzenschussgerät von vorhin. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ihr baut an der TU ein Hubschrauber, den man autonom steuern kann, also von irgendwo steuern kann, damit der eine Fernsehkamera oder in irgendeiner Form eine Kamera transportieren kann, mit der man Veranstaltungen für Nachrichten, was auch immer, solche Sachen filmen kann, oder was wir gerade hatten, für Industrieanlagen, die schwer zugänglich sind, kann er sich auch selbst steuern?
Der kann sich selbst steuern, also das heißt, der braucht im Prinzip, wenn er einmal eine Art Wegpunktliste vom Boden bekommen hat, dann braucht man theoretisch überhaupt keinen Ablink mehr, dann kann er sein Ding machen und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel einen Verbindungsabriss hat, weil in der Regel möchte man ihn schon so betreiben, dass man Kommunikation zum Hubschrauber hat, dann kann man ihn letztendlich auch so programmieren, Wir werden informieren, dass er die Strecke, die er gekommen ist, einfach aus Sicherheitsgründen auch exakt so zurückfliegt und am Startplatz wieder landet.
Und dann bei dir wieder ankommt, während du vor irgendeinem Café dir ein Getränk gerade kommen lässt.
Und wenn der Sprit alle ist, könnt ihr das auch feststellen?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall eine Spritanzeige drin. Wir werden das so einrichten, halt aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass der Hubschrauber immer davon ausgeht, um sicher zu landen, muss er die Strecke, die er gekommen ist, zurückfliegen können.
Wie lange ist da so eine Reichweite?
Also der Hubschrauber wird um die 8 Liter Sprit mitnehmen können. Und wir haben jetzt mit 4 Liter Spritverbrauch pro Stunde kalkuliert. Das ist jetzt noch nicht verifiziert, weil der jetzt noch nicht endgültig aufgebaut und getestet ist.
Das wäre genau meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Ja, der ist jetzt im Prinzip, ja.
Ist er denn schon mal geflogen?
Nein, der noch nicht. Also wir haben die beiden Versionen, die wir davor hatten, die wir auf Modellhubschraubern aufgebaut haben, die sind geflogen. Und wie gesagt, die erste Version hatte schon diesen Robotik-Competition in den USA gewonnen. Und die zweite Version hat dann eben noch sehr an Zuverlässigkeit gewonnen. Also da musste dann auch der Sicherheitspilot nicht mehr übernehmen oder so, was bei dem ersten Hubschrauber durchaus mal passieren konnte, dass er sich in irgendeiner Form aufgeschwungen hat oder dass irgendwelche Sensoren ausgefallen sind oder so, die letztendlich was dazu geführt hat, dass man da händisch wieder rangehen musste und den Hubschrauber runterholen musste. Das soll jetzt natürlich bei der dritten Version überhaupt nicht mehr nötig sein. Was war eigentlich bei der zweiten auch schon nicht mehr.
Und kriegt ihr das hin bis Anfang August? Weil dann will ich euch ja ganz unbedingt bei uns auf dem Camp sehen, weil da werden wir eine Menge solcher Geräte zu sehen kriegen. Unter anderem eben die neue Software von der Micro Drone, von micro drones.de.
Ja, Micro Drone sagt mir auch was, ja.
Also die werden wir da sehen. Wir werden mindestens drei verschiedene Selbstbauprojekte sehen von selbstliegenden Drohnen.
Ich bin jetzt mit euren Camps nicht so vertraut. Wann und wo findet das statt?
8. bis 12. August in der Nähe von Berlin bei Fino-Fort, in der Nähe vom Flughafen Fino auch. Von daher hat er das sozusagen schon mal thematisch ganz gut angesiedelt. Und für 150 Euro Normalpreis kriegt man nach 5 Tagen Rundumversorgung mit Internetkabel im Zelt. Und das kannst du dir noch mal angucken.
Events.ccc.de Also einer von euch hat von mir auch schon eine Mail gekriegt und nicht geantwortet.
Gut, also ihr habt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich vertragen und werdet beim Camp dann miteinander noch mehr technische Dinge austauschen.
Was macht denn euer Hubschrauber, wenn die Sensoren keinen Sinn ergeben?
Was gibt's nicht?
Das gibt's nicht. In der Regel ist es so, wenn die Sensoren sinnieren, dann gibt's auch einen Sinn. Wenn man die Sache wirklich absichern will, müsste man das natürlich redundant ausführen. Man sagt, wenn die eine Sensorik irgendwie komische Sachen gibt. Also er hat auch so eine Art Selbstdiagnose. Also wenn er zum Beispiel eingeschaltet wird und sich am Boden in einem statischen Zustand befindet und er kriegt Sensor-Readings, die einfach keinen Sinn machen, dann würde er niemals abheben.
Tim, der Kallmann-Filter löst das Problem. Der schmeißt einfach die Sachen, die am unwahrscheinlichsten sind, raus.
Da muss ich jetzt mal auch etwas sagen, was euch überraschen wird. Marvin fliegt seit jeher ohne Kallmann-Filter. Und das sehr gut. Bei Kallmann-Filter wird immer so überall gehypt als die universelle Lösung. Und das gerade bei solchen Drohnen-Anwendungen als muss unbedingt sein und geht gar nicht anders. Aber wenn man die Regelung vernünftig löst und sich ein bisschen den Kopf darüber macht, wie man die Sensoren auswertet und wie man diese Sensor Fusion macht, dann geht das auch ohne.
Ja, da muss ich dir recht geben. Also die Microdron fliegt mit Kallmann-Filter, aber die Selbstbauprojekte, die fliegen alle tatsächlich von Hand in Software.
Ich kenne das Plus-Version meiner Programmiererfahrung. Es gibt immer so Stellen im Code, da steht daran Can't Happen. Aber irgendwann kommt man da halt doch nochmal an.
Und es ist dann, wenn die Maschine sagt, Dave, meine Antenne wird in 31, 5 Stunden ausfallen. Okay, Gentlemen, folgender Vorschlag zur Güte, ihr werdet euch entweder online oder aber im Camp noch weiter vertragen. Jörg und ich auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für diese Einblicke.
Ich will noch einen letzten Kommentar abliefern, und zwar wir versuchen oder wir möchten das auf jeden Fall jetzt, da sind wir auch ganz stark dran, bis zur langen Nacht der Wissenschaften, das soweit aufgebaut haben, dass man da sich das auch schon anschauen kann und da ein bisschen was für sich rausziehen kann.
Wie bitte? Die ist wann?
Die ist am 9. Juni.
Okay, also bald.
Genau, und von 17 bis 23 Uhr ist da in unserem Institut, das ist das Institut für Technische Informatik und Mikroelektronik an der TU Berlin. Und da kann man sich auch durchklicken, wenn man auf die TU-Weite geht, tu-berlin.de, dann auf Langen Nacht der Wissenschaften, dann auf Campus Charlottenburg, und dann kommt man im Prinzip auch gleich...
Sag einfach, welches Gebäude das ist.
Das ist das Gebäude 7, also EN-Gebäude, und das ist dann auf der Webseite entsprechend mit deiner 7 markiert. Und wenn man dann da draufklickt, dann ist das auch gleich das erste Projekt, was da angezeigt wird.
Oder man fragt sich zu den Wahnsinnigen durch die fliegende Hubschrauber bauen. Jörg, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Glück für das Gerät. Und wenn der fliegt, dann gib in irgendeiner Form Bescheid, das würden wir gerne dokumentiert sehen.
Ja, danke.
Wir haben eigentlich noch eine knappe halbe Stunde Chaosradio auf Fritz und damit geht's gleich weiter.
Sie sind das Heißeste, was Berlin in Sachen Rockmusik zu bieten hat und sie befinden sich gerade auf großer Deutschlandtour. Die Beat Stakes spielen sich von Reutlingen über Bielefeld bis Rottweil die Fingerwund. Aber nur, um sich auf ihr Heimspiel am 7. Juli in der Berliner Wohlleide vorzubereiten. Die Beatstakes berichten jeden Freitag bei den Radio-Fritzen am Nachmittag von ihren lustigen, aber auch von ihren peinlichen Tour-Erlebnissen in Sachen Sex, Drugs and Rock'n'Roll.
Das Beatstakes Tour-Tagebuch jeden Freitag bei den Radio-Fritzen am Nachmittag und auf fritz.de Entschuldigung, hier sind die Beatstakes. Und das hört man. Fünf nach halb eins. Das Zugpersonal habe Anweisungen, solche Gruppen intern weiterzumelden, sagte ein Konzernsprecher. Im Potsdam haben gestern etwa 1000 Menschen gegen den G8-Gipfel demonstriert. Sie zogen Richtung Schloss Sizilienhof. Dort hatten sich vorher die Außenminister der G8-Staaten getroffen, um den Gipfel in Heiligendamm vorzubereiten. Nach Polizeiangaben verlief die Demonstration überwiegend friedlich. Das internationale Olympische Komitee hat sich in den Doping-Skandal um das frühere Telekom-Team eingeschaltet und eine Disziplinar-Kommission einberufen. Damit muss Jan Ulrich um an seinen Olympiasieg von Sydney 2000 im Straßenrennen sowie um die Silbermedaille im Zeitfahren bangen. Zwei russische Kosmonauten sind aus der internationalen Raumstation ISS ausgestiegen. Sie sollen ein defektes Kabel für das Satellitensystem GPS austauschen sowie Schutzplatten gegen Meteoroideneinschläge am russischen Service-Modul montieren. Der Außenseil-Einsatz soll etwa sechs Stunden dauern. In dieser Nacht gering bewölkt oder klar, es bleibt überall trocken. Tiefstwerte zwischen 10 bis 12 Grad von der Rupina Heide bis zum LBL-Sterkreis 7 bis 9 und in Berlin werden 9 Grad prognostiziert. Morgen zunächst viel Sonne im Tagesverlauf, lockere Quellwolken, aber wieder überall trocken. Die Höchstwerte 20 bis 24 Grad. Wir haben keine Meldungen, wünschen gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Chaosradio 124, die letzte gute Viertelstunde auf Fritz.
Ich hab mich gefragt, ob der Hubschrauber schwarz ist.
Ob der Hubschrauber schwarz ist? Wieso sollte der Hubschrauber schwarz sein?
Dann sieht man ihn nachts nicht.
Hubschrauber müssen schwarz sein. Wenn ist er auf jeden Fall mattschwarz. Kurze Einladung, falls ihr gerade reingeschnickelt seid, Schrauben 2.0, die Chaosradio Hobby-Thek, wir reden heute über Dinge selber bauen, entweder weil es Spaß macht oder weil sie nützlich sind oder weil man sie einfach mal irgendwann erfinden musste. Wir hatten vor den Nachrichten gerade Jorg von der TU am Telefon, der hat erzählt, dass die einen großen, 2, 50 langen Hubschrauber selber bauen, mit dem unter anderem Kameras transportiert werden können für professionelle Anwendungen, was auch immer. Und wenn man die letzten zweieinhalb Stunden etwa zusammenfasst, kann man feststellen, dass es viele Dinge gibt, die man so irgendwo kaufen kann und dann weiter modifizieren kann und sich nicht damit abfinden muss, was der Handel oder die Konsumgesellschaft oder der... die Güterindustrie einem vorgibt und sagt, hier haste, jetzt benutzt du es mal. Ja, einerseits ja, was fertige Endprodukte betrifft. Auf der anderen Seite ist genau dieser Handel und diese Konsumgesellschaft der jetzigen Zeit natürlich auch ein großer Benefit an der ganzen Geschichte. Und zwar ja nicht in dem Aspekt, dass sie dir jetzt die Notwendigkeit eines Selbstbaus abnehmen, sondern an vielen Stellen einfach den Selbstbau von komplexeren Einheiten, sag ich mal, ermöglichen. Dadurch, dass man eben heutzutage in den Laden gehen kann, von mir aus auch den Laden, der in den 15 Zoll vor seinem Kopf da sich abspielt und sich einfach mal in den Motor klicken kann, wie der Anrufer vorher schon zur Sprache gebracht hat, oder eben auch mal ein GPS-Modul. Weil ja, bei aller Liebe, aber das hätte man vor zehn Jahren tatsächlich noch selber löten müssen oder für wirklich richtig teure Geld kaufen müssen. Und da wäre man an einer sehr frühen Stelle sozusagen schon verappt und das ist heutzutage eine wirklich, ja doch Revolution, das ist immer so ein inflationärer Begriff. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, GPS gibt es heutzutage für zweistellige Eurobeträge. Als fertig funktionierende Einheit, Motoren gibt es auch in vielen Preisklassen. Mikrocontroller sind auf den unter irgendwie 10 Euro Bereich geschrumpft, die Tools, die dazu notwendigen Softwarewerkzeuge sind. Simpler geworden in der Bedienung, Benutzung und frei verfügbar. Keine Multitausend Dollar Entwicklungsumgebung mehr, wo man irgendwelche Ingenieursstudienjahre zur Bedienung vorher investieren muss. Sondern das hat man sich in drei Tagen zusammenarbeitet, mit bisschen rum googeln und ein paar PDFs lesen. Ihr habt vorhin schon ein paar Webseiten genannt. Gibt es da so einen Punkt, an dem man sich bei den aktuellen Stand der Dinge informieren kann?
Na immer interessantes mikrocontroller.net. Da findet man eben eine Menge zu diesen ganzen Mikrocontrollern. Und auch auch DevKids. Wie kriegt man die programmiert? Wie kriegt man da sinnvolle Ergebnisse aus in wirkliche Step-by-Step-Anleitungen? Und letztlich, wenn man was machen will, was ein bisschen lebendig ist, braucht man irgendeinen Chip, irgendeinen Prozessor. Und dafür sind diese Microcontroller Atmel zum Beispiel für 1, 50 Euro oder was. Die haben eine Leistungsfähigkeit heute für 1, 50. Die sind von der Reihen-Processing-Power her sind die so mächtig wie damals der C64. Das muss man sich einfach vor Augen führen. Die gibt es jetzt für 1, 50. Da sind, was weiß ich, 28 Beinchen dran. Und da kann man eben eine Menge Dinge steuern und regeln. Da mal eben einen Fernsteuerservo zu kontrollieren. Das ist eine Software, das ist ein 5-Zeiler. Und das zu programmieren, das ist für jemanden, der dieses Setup mal hat, der sich mal damit auseinandergesetzt hat, wie kriege ich ein Programmchen in diesem Chip, damit einen Controller zu bauen, der 10 oder 5 Servos fernsteuert, irgendwie bedienen kann über eine Elektronik. Das ist eine Sache von einer Stunde. So, das ist keine Mühe mehr heute.
Und ein Programmiergerät dafür, sage ich mal, kann man schlicht und ergreifend auch für sehr schmale Geld kaufen und sich auf die eigentliche Bastelarbeit konzentrieren und muss sich nicht an so einer Stelle denn wieder... Verzetteln und ja, es geht nicht, es programmiert nicht und schade, ich komme nicht weiter.
Auf zu Segoa.
Auf zu Segoa. Irgendwie die Plastikkarte eingepackt und shoppen gegangen.
Segoa ist hier so ein sehr befehlenswerter Elektronikhändler in Berlin, die so alles haben, was man eigentlich so braucht.
Ja, oft als Apotheke verschrien, aber wenn man mal wirklich...
Es geht nicht zu Konrad, der zahlt dir das Doppelte bis Dreifache. Wenn es gar nicht anders geht, dann noch zu Reichelt.
So viel zu den praktischen Hinweisen. Sonst muss man auch sagen, es ist immer sehr sinnvoll, sich auch gleich mal so eine Community zu suchen. Im Netz gibt es eigentlich zu jedem Thema immer irgendetwas, weil in dem Moment, wo man nicht mehr weiterkommt, dann braucht man natürlich auch Rat. Da ist das Netz eine große Hilfe.
Und damit sind wir wieder bei einem der Anfangsthemen der Sendung, was auch in dem Ankündigungstext drin stand. Man bastelt an irgendwas, kommt nicht weiter. Oder aber, wenn man irgendwas entdeckt hat, macht man das insoweit öffentlich, damit andere Leute entweder von den Erfahrungen profitieren oder aber sagen, das geht auch anders, das geht besser, das kann man modifizieren, daraus kann man noch was anderes machen.
Genau, also auch wenn man jetzt gerade was Komplexeres startet, warum nicht auch gleich noch einen Blog dazu einrichten und einfach über die eigenen Erfahrungen schrittweise, wie sie eben passieren, berichten, dann kriegt man sicherlich auch irgendwann Kommentare und andere Leute, die das zufällig finden oder was weiß ich, spricht sie vielleicht auch rum, wenn es ein interessantes Projekt ist. Man ist nicht allein.
Das wird man sehr schnell feststellen, dass viele Leute meistens auf dieselbe Probleme, an die man gerade knuspert, irgendwie auch schon mal gestoßen sind und einige von denen möglicherweise auch schon eine Lösung irgendwann mal erfunden haben.
Noch viel interessanter sind die Sachen, auf die man selber nie gekommen wäre, die einem dann aber unendlich viele neue Ideen bescheren, wie irgendwelche Leute, die mit billigsten Microcontrollern, die so programmieren, dass man die direkt an den Video-Input des Fernsehers anschließen kann und dann da ein Videobild, also einen Text oder ein Game auf seinem Fernseher anzeigen kann. Oder, dass man mit so einem 1, 50 Euro Atmel-Microcontroller tatsächlich eine USB 1.1-Schnittstelle bedienen kann und das auch eigentlich funktionieren sollte, nur das ist viel noch nicht hingekriegt.
Der kostet 82. Ihr habt anfangs gesagt, es gibt Unmengen dieser Projekte, über die es zu sprechen und sich zu erzählen. So viel Zeit werden wir nicht haben. Welche sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen?
Erwähnen müssen wir unbedingt noch. Die 3D-Plotter, finde ich. Wir müssen Multitouch erwähnen. Was müssen wir da noch mal überlegen?
Dann fangen wir doch erstmal irgendwas an.
Was ist 3D-Plotter?
3D-Plotter gibt es auch schon seit einigen Jahren. Es ist erstmal im Industriebereich eingesetzt worden zum Prototyping. Wir probieren das erstmal aus, ob das grundsätzlich so funktioniert, wenn man irgendwelche Rohre, Flansche und so. Man will erstmal irgendwas haben, ohne gleich eine Produktionsstraße dafür anzuwerfen. Es gibt eben Geräte, denen man digitale 3D-Modelle liefern kann. Die bauen das dann quasi aus dem Nichts vor den eigenen Augen auf. Es gibt verschiedene Techniken, die da so entwickelt wurden über die Zeit. Ich weiß nicht, was gerade so super hip ist, aber geil finde ich die Dinge, die in so einer Flüssigkeit einfach einen Laser hineinsteuern und dann sozusagen Schicht für Schicht aus dieser flüssigen Masse, dadurch, dass der Laser die an einer bestimmten Stelle verhärtet und mit dem Rest verklebt, entsteht dann sozusagen aus dieser Ursuppe auf einmal etwas, was danach auch sehr robust sein kann.
Also womit man dann notfalls auch ausprobieren kann, kann man da Nagel reindrehen oder wie sieht es aus, wenn man das irgendwie schräg hält?
Ja, passt das, ist das funktional?
Also es ist kein Bild auf dem Bildschirm, es ist richtig ein dreidimensionales Objekt, was man in die Hand nehmen kann. 3D zum in die Hand nehmen und gerade für so Geräteentwicklungen, jetzt hier so kleine, was weiß ich, ein Handy irgendwie, ich denke mir gerade eins aus und ich will es wirklich mal in der Hand halten. Schade, dass wir das nicht die ganze Zeit, mein Cut-Modell vor mir irgendwie sich drehen haben, selbst mit holographischem Display kann ich es nicht anfassen. Ich muss es in die Hand nehmen und für genau diese Problemstellungen, wurden mal diese 3D-Plotter da im Industriebereich ursprünglich mal entworfen. Und da geht es jetzt eben tatsächlich mit Heißkleber, das ist ja eigentlich auch ein sehr naheliegendes Medium, um 3D-Objekte zu konstruieren. Und mit Zucker gibt es wohl auch einen.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch einen mit Nylonpulver, der soll auch kommerziell dann angeboten werden. Allerdings, und das entsteht eben aus solchen Selbstbauprojekten, dass sich daraus kleine Firmen entwickeln und sagen, wir können das aber viel billiger als diese monströsen gigantischen Firmen, die damit eine Menge Geld verdienen. Und die bieten jetzt einen 3D-Drucker demnächst für unter 1000 Dollar an. Desktop Factory heißen die. Und drucken dann Zeugs mit Nylonpulver, das dann irgendwie zusammengebacken wird.
Wird es dann werden wie mit den Tintenstrahldruckern, dass das Nylonpulver dann unheimlich teuer ist? Wahrscheinlich. Und Mutti fragt die ganze Zeit, wo sind meine Strumpfhosen hin? Multitouch habt ihr noch angerissen.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal kurz bevor ich es vergesse, lassen hier eine ganze Menge URLs fallen. Wir können hier jetzt gerade alle selber nicht notieren. Üblicherweise haben wir da den sehr aktiven Chat. Und es gibt ja zu jeder Chaosradio Sendung auch eine Mitmachseite. Wikikaosradio ccc.de, da ist zu jeder Sendung immer was drin. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass die ganzen URLs, die wir jetzt genannt haben, irgendwie halbwegs automatisch ihren Weg reinfinden. Wenn sich da jemand die Mühe machen möchte, ist wahrscheinlich schon geschehen. Aber ich sag's einfach trotzdem nochmal. Und wer nachschlagen möchte, ist das immer der richtige Ort. Ja, also 3D Plotter.
Das muss ich unbedingt erwähnen. Fab at Home ist das offizielle Selbstbauprojekt für 3D Plotter.
Bau dir deine eigene Fabrik.
www.fabathome.org Bau dir deinen eigenen 3D Materie-Compiler.
Genau, und Heißkleber gibt's jetzt auch in Multicolor. Okay, wir haben noch 10 Minuten.
Naja, das ist ja gerade in aller Munde, weil Apple jetzt mit diesem iPhone rauskommt. Da kann man dann nicht nur draufklicken, sondern auch gleich mit zwei Fingern arbeiten. Das ist gerade ein ganz heißes Eisen, weil man natürlich dann endlich diesen Traum des ich fummel mit 10 Fingern auf einem Display rum und jeder tut irgendetwas, mal langsam sich erfüllen kann. Da fummeln auch gerade viele Leute dran. Gibt dir ein schönes Projekt in Berlin. Und Krota, du hast die Website irgendwie rausgesucht?
www.multi-touch.de Wer hätte es gedacht? Ein Projekt der Seabase, die auf Basis dieser Infrarot-Kamera-Optik-Erkennung mal so ein Multitouch nachgebaut hat.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein geiles Gerät. Wie groß ist das? Wie so eine Reisekoffer, so eine Milchglas-Scheibe. Und von unten gibt es einen Projektor, der dann erstmal so ein Bild darauf projiziert. Schön alles sichtbar. Und außerdem ist unten noch eine Wärmebildkamera.
Na ja, eine Infrarotkamera.
Ja, also ist dasselbe. Wie auch immer. Man fummelt also dann mit seinen Fingern rum und diese Infrarotkamera sieht sozusagen die Hände, weil sie ja warm sind. Und kann damit auch erkennen, wie nah man dran ist und dann eben auch genau den Punkt rauskriegen, wenn man nun wirklich auf diese...
Da muss ich mal knirren. Das stimmt so nicht. Da wird von der Seite reingeleuchtet mit Infrarotstrahlen und da, wo der Finger die Schreibe berührt, gibt es den Effekt der Totalreflektion. Der wird dann aufgehoben und deswegen sieht man an der Stelle per Optik den Finger.
Ne, ne, das neue Modell kann tatsächlich auch den Abstand erkennen. Das heißt, du kannst nicht nur durch das Klicken, also durch den Punkt, wo du drauf machst...
Dann bist du ein weiter als ich, okay.
Na, die sind schon ein weiter. Ich hab mir das vor ein paar Tagen erst nochmal angeschaut. Also man kann auch schon dadurch, dass man nur darüber schwebt, schon bestimmte Dinge machen. Das sieht man auch ganz gut daneben. Da ist noch so ein Kontrollmonitor, wo das Infrarotbild sozusagen auch nochmal angezeigt wird. Dann wird das schon sehr schön klein. Das ist auch wieder ein schönes Beispiel für so einfache Technik, mit der man ziemlich geile Sachen machen kann. Dann hat man so einen riesen Bildschirm durch diesen Projektor und kann da eben ein Klavier drauf spielen.
Es gibt ein anderes Multitouch Projekt, das an der Stelle nicht unerwähnt bleiben soll. Das basiert darauf, dass man längs und quer ganz viele Leiter, also Kabel, möglichst durchsichtige, dünne Kabel, sodass man es nicht sieht, auf diesen Screen packt. Die eben isoliert sind, sich aber jeweils an Punkten kreuzen. Da packt man ein 400 Kilohertz Signal auf so ein Kabel und das wird dann in das andere Kabel eingestreut. Also auf dem Querkabel 400 Kilohertz, auf dem Längskabel sieht man die. Wenn man jetzt mit dem Finger da in die Nähe kommt, dann wirkt der Finger wie ein Kondensator, also wie eine Kapazität und verstimmt damit das Einstreuen des Signals an diesen Kreuzungspunkt. Wenn man das jetzt multiplox, kann man zu jedem Kreuzungspunkt eben dieses Verstimmen eines Fingers detektieren. Man sieht also sozusagen...
Wenn zwei Finger dann sozusagen auf der gleichen Linie sind?
Naja, du hast die Kabel in einem Zentimeter Abstand und dann kriegst du gar nicht zwei Finger in so ein Feld hinein.
Okay, also schon so eine Matrix.
Ist eine Matrix. Es hat Sony ursprünglich mal gebaut. 2002 ist es dann total in Vergessenheit geraten. Und übrigens das iPhone Touch funktioniert genauso. Das ist von der Firma, ich glaube, fingertips.com, die gab es früher mal, ich gucke gerade, fingerworks.com. Ursprünglich entwickelt worden, zwei Profs irgendwo aus Amiland und dann gekauft von Apple und Balta in Deutschland, produziert das jetzt für die. Das sind so durchsichtige Folien mit Kabeln drauf. Das kann man selber bauen. Das geht mit zwei Atmel-Controllern und einem Op-Amp. Und das muss man ein bisschen multiplexen und ein bisschen Software finden. Das ist ein Operationsverstärker, der das Empfangssignal von dem Empfangskäbelchen sozusagen – weil das so dünne Signale sind – ja, das wird ein bisschen verstärkt und dann kann man eben den Finger auch kommen sehen. Das ist tatsächlich theoretisch für unter 15 bis 20 Euro zu bauen im Selbstbaubereich.
Das nur als kleinen Einblick, diese vergangenen drei Stunden, als kleinen Einblick in die Welt der Dinge, die man bauen kann oder die man, wenn man ein bisschen sucht, finden kann, wo man denkt, schön, dass es sowas gibt, ich habe eine Idee dazu. Wenn ihr eine Idee zu dieser Sendung habt, könnt ihr euch gerne daran beteiligen. Tim, magst du noch mal ganz kurz die ganzen Kommunikationsbasisgeschichten durchgeben?
Ja, also über Feedback freuen wir uns ja generell. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist da die E-Mail-Adresse, wo ihr was hinschicken solltet, wenn ihr irgendetwas zur Sendung abzugeben habt. Ansonsten, wie schon erwähnt, das Wiki zum Chaosradio. Wiki Chaosradio.ccc.de, jetzt auch über HTTPS.
Es gibt einen Podcast.
Da kann man sich einfach niedermachen. Chaosradio gibt es als Podcast zum Nachhören. Es gibt nach wie vor, auch wenn es gerade aus bestimmten Gründen etwas eingeschlafen ist, Chaosradio Express, noch mal so als Begleitprogramm, wenn sicherlich viele von euch schon entdeckt haben. Generell gibt es bei Chaosradio.ccc.de diverse Podcastfeeds. Da kommt demnächst auch noch ein bisschen was dazu. Hoffe ich, wenn ich mal wieder einen neuen Computer habe, dann wird das vielleicht auch ein schönes Jahr.
Das war Chaosradio 124 mit Tim Steini und Fidl vom Chaos Computer Club. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart.
Und Jakob.
Selbstverständlich. Wir hören uns wieder, also wir wahrscheinlich öfter. Das Chaosradio hört ihr wieder am letzten Mittwoch im Juno. Da weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, welcher es ist, aber es wird irgendwie der 30. oder 27. müsste das sein. Der 30. ist ein Samstag. Ohne online zu sein. Also am 27. gibt es das nächste Chaosradio, was auf jeden Fall jetzt kommt, ist der Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf, der jede Menge fantastischer britischer Pop- und Indie-Musik und sonstige Geschichten in seiner Kiste hat. Wir sagen Dankeschön, wiedersehen, bis zum nächsten Mal. Fahrt vorsichtig und fast nicht in die Steckdose.
Tschüss.